und jetzt wo noch keiner da ist kann ich jetzt noch mal einfach erzählen wie es ist nämlich
0w größer keckw es ist einfach die wahrheit es will keiner wahr haben 2022 aber hier habt
es gehört so sieht es aus 0w ist das bessere emote ist ja was das deprimierende ist an den
beiden emotes beides sind tot kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen aber ich meine man überlegt
es ist es ist eigentlich schlimm überlegt mal von den emotes gatschi bus ist es ist tot keckw ist
tot 0w ist tot meine güte kann man richtig bedenken
so erster das stimmt denn angeblich fünf leute im stream einer davon bist du einer ist mein
forscher rechner also gibt es noch drei weitere die hier rum lurken die wahrscheinlich noch den
browser seit drei wochen offen haben und das gar nicht mitbekommen mal gucken bis der discord
checkt mal gucken bis der discord checkt das ich auch bin ich weiß nicht wie lange ich heute
da bin kommt darauf an wie schnell wir das hinbekommen wenn überhaupt und wie es mit dem
hals aussieht und wanns und wann es pepo fett gibt weil irgendwann demnächst gibt es hier auch
pepo fett hapa hapa pepo hyper fett beides zwei gesaugter huge ich zeige euch mal schnell um was
es geht vor alle anderen eintreffen lull ich muss das nachher noch mal zeigen und zwar ich
habe im keller den respekt stehen ein dreier ist auch egal was das für einer ist vollkommen
wurscht jetzt jetzt hat's twitch wohl mitbekommen dass das stream online ist kampfkevin moin stein
artler ist am stand unik randy fps kampfkevin danke für den sub zehn monate der unbenannte
der unbenannte obensorz liku ist auch da goldstronic der marcel mr. lolf serolium renax ist auch am
stand beit crafter kommentator pock pock pock hyper pock pock gasm gibt's das ich trau mich
ich trau mich nicht ich trau mich nicht danach zu suchen ja gibt es natürlich was sonst wundert
mich nicht dass es das gibt es auch als animatoren
moin cupilo morpheus 15 monate hypersubscription hier wahnsinn ob ich hab das passen die mod
das soll für drei runtergeladen dass er heute in stress ist nein weil ich kein bock auf mail
punkt ru anti cheat habe leute zahre ich hab das installiert mit dem an installieren bleibt mail
ru anti cheat immer noch drauf karl 15 monate pock ja mail ru anti cheat mail ru anti cheat
ich meine die sagen natürlich das ist nichts schlimmes und macht ja nix und so in meinem
prinzip wird es wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr machen als alle anderen an die cheats aber ich
traue den kommets dann noch weniger was der preischirm der ist daun rauls dange für den
sub ist offline weil geld und wartung zu ja geld nicht so wirklich auch hätte ich bezahlt
kein problem 45 euro im monat gekostet hätte ich bezahlt aber ich müsste mich schon darum
kümmern dass die crawler aktuell bleiben so leute ich zeige euch mal kurz was es kann
sein dass das easy as fuck ist und wir das in ein paar minuten hinkriegen oder auch nicht ich
weiß es nicht und zwar ich habe im keller ein raspberry pi stehen noch ein dreier und
da dran habe ich einen automation hat also p hat aber fett klingt in dem fall besser
und der habe ich überhaupt den ja genau so ein ding habe ich dran und zwar das eigentlich
ist das ding ziemlich cooles bord wie viele tabs ja moment das sind nicht alle tabs ich
habe hier noch mal einen browser offen ja das reicht nicht ich meine so lang chrome nicht
mindestens acht gigabyte ram verbraucht ist es eh und der just ja sollte man auf dem raspberry
pi das 64 bit os installieren geht das überhaupt ist das überhaupt die richtige cpu dafür
das weiß ich gar nicht ob das überhaupt geht das muss arm v8 sein hatte guck mal da mal
anscheinend ja wenn das geht dann würde ich das schon machen nachdem das 64 spit os jetzt
offiziell released ist sehe ich da kein problem drin ich meine so wirklich riesen vorteile
des 64 spit os nicht der größte vorteil von dem 64 spit os ist dass du mehr als ich jetzt
kein best erzählen 2 gigabyte dreieinhalb gigabyte vier gigabyte zumindest dass du
ram ansprechen kannst ohne pae heißt das glaube ich physical address was heißt pae
ram heißt was heißt der kram noch mal physical address extension ohne dass du pae brauchst
obei ist das überhaupt auf dem armen so ich habe keine ahnung bevor ich miss erzählen
aber wenn es funktioniert dann dann schadet das auf jeden fall nichts so ich mache mal
kurz meine vm an oder meine vm wie die coolen leute das sagen der desktop was habt ihr
immer mit meinem desktop ist der beste desktop massif sogar die katze liegt entspannt auf
dem desktop das ist der ist pokaster desktop ich finde alles ich finde alles der desktop
ist bei mir ein ganz normaler ordner wie alles andere auch warum nicht die pngs in einen
ordner tun dann hätte ich ja noch einen unterordner laut alles plotet steuer erkläre oh nee das
muss ich auch noch mein steuerberater hat mich schon angeschrieben ich muss noch reste
einreichen was offiziell was haben wir dafür in hintergrund bing image of the day sind
das fahrtfinder was sehe ich denn hier ok bing moment bing image of the day ich brauche
es die erklärung zu dem bild zeig mal her bing image of the day
woher weiß ich überhaupt was was bing image of the day ist irgendjemand eine ahnung was
mein hintergrund bild sein soll sieht aus wie fahrtfinder fahrtfinder von 1915 oder so
keine ahnung bing image of the day bing bing lässt mich nicht mehr runternavigieren
seht ihr das ja ich benutze auch nur bing image of the day sonst verwende ich von bing
nichts real shades dankeschön für zwei monate massive subscription so bin ich jetzt stehengeblieben
genau also ich wollte euch ich wollte euch was zeigen und zwar ich habe im keller ein
raspberry pi ich glaube das wollte ich euch in der vm zeigen also ich habe ein raspberry
pi 3 im keller mit einem automation fat dran und das board ist eigentlich ganz nice das
hier ist der ap endpoint hat mir selbst ein tool gebastelt das die bilder runterlädt
von bing ja ich weiß was der ap endpoint ist ich habe aber keine ahnung was ist da ah
da sieht man glaube ich was es ist oder zack bing image wallpaper aha aha rehart quotas
der armor alles klar ja welches bild davon habe ich denn keine ahnung es war auch egal
so wir gucken uns das hintere bild nicht an ok also ich wollte euch ja was zeigen und zwar
ich mache mal kurz flashbang modus an muss jetzt kurz sein und wir müssen wir müssen
zu pimme pimme roni automation p hat so erkläre ich mal kurz wo das problem ist automation
p hat 5 hat p hat hat so das ist das falsche wo ist denn ihre shop seite haben die haben
die das nicht mehr kann das sein haben die das nicht mehr ist das ist das ist das grip
ach es ist jetzt der automation hat mini auch immer es gibt neun den habe ich mir sogar
bestellt nicht irgendwie liegen nicht dass du trotz lange rede kurzer sinn also was habe
ich am start ich habe unten im keil an respite 3 stehen der steht da schon seit drei viertel
ja ja daran ist angeschlossen meine heizung um die heizung auslesen zu können und daran
ist dieser automation fett angeschlossen und der hat folgende features hier sieht man es
eigentlich ganz gut der hat ein relay zum schalten also das hier das tat ein relay zum schalten
übrigens ich lasse euch jetzt mal teilen haben weil das habe ich auch erst letztens
gelernt für was das steht bei einem relay steht no für normally open und nc für normally
closed also sprich wenn das relay nicht geschaltet ist dann ist das quasi dann fließt das strom
hier durch so und wenn es relay nicht geschaltet ist und hier dran angeschlossen fließt das
nicht also bei dem einen muss man schalten und bei dem anderen nicht hört sich nicht
so an aber mein halt ist tatsächlich besser es ist jetzt alles etwas lockerer und ich
hoffe das ist bald überstanden joho dankeschön für den sub akrige ja besser nimmt mal zeit
für neues video also zumindest als ein relay du hast drei überleg gerade wirklich drei
anscheinend drei analog digital konverter wusste ich gar nicht dass man da drei stück
hat das wichtigste analog digital konverter der den habe ich den den habe ich in benutzung
und zwar wie gesagt ein raspberry pi ist meine heizung und einem raspberry pi ist also
er läuft da läuft der heiz champ drauf der heiz champ haben wir zusammen im stream programmiert
das ist das ding womit ich über homosystem eine heizungssteuerung mache darauf läuft
so ein kleines sieb programm um mich anzurufen auf dem handy bei speziellen ereignissen und
es ist an diesem analog digital konverter ist ein draht von der klingel angeschlossen
ist dieses protokoll von der klingel ist ein bisschen pepega und zwar es liegen darauf
ungefähr 17 einhalb bis 18 volt an im ruhezustand 22 volt wenn es klingelt 15 volt wenn einer
den gegensprechanlagen höre abgenommen hat und dann wieder zurück auf 18 volt das heißt
ich kann theoretisch mit diesem analog digital konverter erkennen wann es geklingelt hat
und wann nicht aktuell brauche ich das nicht weil ich habe an meiner gegensprechanlage
so ein ding was ich mir auf ebay gekauft habe vom hersteller wenn es klingelt ruft mich
das an und dann kriege ich auf dem handy mit wenn es klingelt die haben ein repo ich weiß
ich weiß und die sache ist jetzt die ich möchte dieses ding vom hersteller ablösen
weil ich benutze die gegensprechoption nicht was ich machen will ist und das haben wir
auch schon mal zusammen im stream getestet was ich machen will ist ich möchte dass der
raspberry pi mich anruft per zip auf ein voiprogramm auf meinem handy und in diesen call die kamera
den stream von meiner kamera vom hoftor als video call einbindet das ist kein problem
das funktioniert prinzipiell die sache ist bloß die ich muss mitbekommen wenn es klingelt
damit ich den call starten kann und dass es geklingelt hat bekomme ich mit wenn diese
analog digital konverter sagt es ist über 20 volt das problem ist jetzt nur was ich
damit habe dass es für das ding zwar eine library in python gibt aber es gibt für das
ding keine library für dotnet und mein zipprogramm ist in dotnet die sache ist nur die natürlich
könnte ich das machen wie der letzte kaknoob und einfach ein dotnet konzolenprogramm machen
was dann quasi von irgendeinem python script aufgerufen wird sobald es klingelt aber wir
sind ja nicht hier um den einfachen weg zu gehen wir gucken heute mal wie wir diesen
sensor in dotnet auslesen können und das dumme ist es gibt es gibt zwar was dafür das
habe ich auch schon mal ganz kurz probiert aber das funktioniert nicht und die library
ist unmaintained also ich fürchte wir müssen da selbst ein bisschen rum basteln dass das
tut so dass das was ich heute vor habe ach ja und übrigens das teil an sich wenn ihr
auch so was machen wollt kann ich das board empfehlen das habe ich jetzt schon eine weile
im einsatz von der idee her ist das wirklich sehr nice du hast drei analog digital konverter
einen relay und relay braucht man immer mal das relay macht aber maximal 24 volt also
ihr könnt damit jetzt kein irgendwelche wirklich fetten fetten geräte schalten oder
so aber 24 volt reicht für die meisten sachen 24 volt relay outputs ich glaube mit maximal
500 milliampere und inputs in die inputs sind im prinzip so a gpi aus nur für bis zu 24
volt weil der raspberry pi hat keine 24 volt input das heißt was relay eins das relay
warum soll ich das warum soll ich das was soll ich das relay nennen das ist ja wie
jubantu anstatt ubuntu also sprich du hast gpio inputs für 24 volt was der raspberry
pi normalerweise nicht hat und du kannst bis zu drei geräte sogar da drüber mit strom
versorgen mit den outputs allerdings maximal 500 milliampere was aber auch für nahezu alles
reicht so so sieht es aus und das probieren wir jetzt mal ein shelly ist ähnlich nein
ja und nein der shelly ist für 230 volt gedacht den shelly eins kannst du glaube ich auch
für 12 volt betrieb umjumpern glaube ich zumindest mal ob der shelly eins ist das den
du umschalten kannst mit jumper falls man das hier sieht ja guck der shelly hat hier
einen jumper und ich glaube du kannst den jelly damit umjumpern 230 volt auf 12 volt
wenn du damit 12 volt schalten willst das ding ist hier bis maximal 24 volt allerdings
mehr da drüber wirst du es wahrscheinlich grillen deswegen ist keine so gute idee aber
ja es ist im prinzip zumindest ähnlich zum shelly insofern dass es ein relay drauf hat
der shelly hat aber natürlich noch eine ecke mehr der shelly hat dann ein web interface
und mqtt integration in der standard firmware und sowas in der richtung übrigens soll
ich euch mal was sagen er erinnert er erinnert sich noch einer daran wo wir die kogeek steckdosenleiste
geflasht haben husa hat eine frage guck ich guck ich gleich ähm erinnert euch jetzt bestimmt
noch an die steckdosenleiste oder nein nicht die die da die da die gute alte kogeek steckdosenleiste
und ich habe mir bei amazon letztens von hammer eine bestellt weil die genauso ausgesehen
hat äh usb steckdosenleiste die da von hammer und ja hammer sackt normalerweise aber wobei
naja hammer ist jetzt vielleicht nicht der inbegriff von von super krassen zeug aber
das ist exakt die gleiche china chinesen steckdosenleiste wie die hier das ist also quasi nicht wirklich
hammer das ist hammer rebrand und ich habe mir die bestellt vor nicht all zu langer zeit
und die lässt sich immer noch tazmota flaschen also wenn irgendjemand customfirmware für
eine steckdosenleiste flaschen möchte und eine steckdosenleiste sucht für die tazmota
fähig ist also wo noch ein esp 2866 drin ist dann nehmen die die geht noch zu flaschen
ota flashbar ja ota flashbar gestern gemacht guck mal was die leute hier sagen ich will
trotzdem immer bei den bei den bewertungen gucken weil vielleicht hatte ich einfach nur
glück was ich gekriegt habe und die haben auch schon mittlerweile unterschiedliche sachen
so tazmota sort by most recent geht nicht pech leute anscheinend anscheinend kriegt man
auch also bei mir ist es aber schon ein bisschen länger her was ist denn sag ich ja guck mal
gleich also bei mir ist schon ein bisschen länger her wo ich die gekauft habe ich habe
mir einmal hier eine für stream gekauft danach habe ich mir noch ein paar gekauft und ich
habe mir glaube ich im januar habe ich mir noch welche gekauft und da die habe ich gestern
geflecht das ging aber anscheinend geht das bei den aller neuesten nicht mehr oder aber
was auch sein kann der typ ist nicht in der lage das zu machen genau siehst du im januar
ging das noch vielleicht ist das aber gose und sp1 wer ist denn mediarad wenn er schon
video das motor fertig geflecht und eingerichtet was ist mediarad ist das so wie hardware rad
nur für medias moment moment moment kann das sein dass diese bewertung eigentlich nur
werbung ist von mediarad dass die dass die im prinzip tschibane dass die tschibane dass
die einfach sagen hey das wäre richtig big brain werbung bei amazon zu machen messer
pfeiffer das das wäre um mich zu sagen das wäre so ich kenne den shop nicht was haben
die denn es soll ich lass mich gerade ein bisschen side tracken und guck mal die haben
die haben blaue wago klemmen gibt sie auch im blau oder haben sie die in die farbe geschmissen
gosund die haben wir auch schon die sind tatsächlich gut das sind die mit den usb steckern unten
dran glaube ich wenn das die mit dem usb stecker unten dran sind dann es ist natürlich äußerst
unforteilhaft dieses ding nie von unten zu fotografieren dass man nicht sieht ob die
das mit usb sind oder nicht sollten die mit usb sein dann sind die wirklich nice da habe
ich nämlich auch noch ich finde das aber ziemlich cool dass die sachen schon fix und fertig
mit das motor verkaufen das ist tatsächlich eine kleine marktlücke das finde ich finde
ich gut aber steckdosen leiste mit nur drei wenn man eine mit vier haben kann die idee
finde ich aber echt cool das motorgeräte was haben die denn alles das interessiert mich
jetzt das interessiert mich jetzt tatsächlich gut ich meine die cellys die kann jeder selbst
flaschen das ist wirklich easy as fuck brauchen wir nix zumal die offizielle celly firmen
wäre auch nicht schlecht ist und alles unterstützt was man so braucht gosund die sich ja umbenennen
in gesund sobald corona vorbei ist recycle choke ich weiß ich weiß ich muss das aber
prinzipiell jedes mal sagen weil das ist so ein mittlerweile pains champiger witz was
haben wir sonst noch moment das ist da ist das motor wo hyper relay ich habe selten
ein board gesehen wo der spd platziert hat drauf aussieht ok da kannst du aber ganz
schön gachi bass relayen eigentlich übel so ein ding steckdosen noch mehr relays cellys
noch mehr reles neun seiten das gucken wir uns jetzt alles an aber ich finde es gut das
muss ich unbedingt bookmarken den shop ich finde es gut dass es mittlerweile in so einem
deutschen shop gibt der sachen das motor preflash verkauft finde ich eine gute sache gut so
noch sind ja so die klassischen das motor dinger schlechthin das motor hieß ja sogar
früher mal irgendwas mit so noch so noch irgendwas so noch das motor wahrscheinlich
für das ns panel ja das blöde am ns panel ist ich weiß ich ich finde das ns panel cool
also das ns panel ist das mit dem touch screen aber ich weiß nicht was ich damit machen soll
von der idee her finde ich das äußerst nice ich weiß aber nicht was das motor dafür
kann und die sache ist halt die was was willst du damit machen wetterbericht braucht kein
mensch wetterbericht ist so die standard app die jeder hat und es ist fucking teuer
ja keine ahnung vielleicht als mini dashboard oder so bin ich reich nur weil ich nicht arm
bin heißt nicht automatisch dass man reich ist also nur dabei nur weil ich was zu essen
kaufen kann wobei kann ich das ich habe ziemlich viele subscriber eingebüßt in letzter zeit
weil ich durch meine erkältungsgeschichte oder besser gesagt als geschichte wenig gestreamt
habe weiß gar nicht ob ich noch was zu essen kaufen kann mit das motor nice ja ja wie was
haben die denn sonst noch dimmer shelly vintage retro lab ne nicht wirklich das braucht man
nicht glaube ich muss unbedingt was trinken hydrated stain hydrated stain ganz wichtig
die haben wir auch erinnert sich noch einer daran erinnert ihr euch noch daran erinnert
sich kurz zeigen archiv ich blick nicht mehr durch leute wo ist denn jetzt das neue archiv
was das series max gemacht hat wo ist das denn war das nicht hier das ist das google
drive warum ist das nicht verlinkt
ah hier gosund nein deck das da oder
wo ist das suchen kann man auch nicht gescheit ich finde es nicht mehr ich finde es nicht
mehr ich wollte es zeigen wo ich wo ich die steckdosen leiste nicht aufbekommen habe wie
viele tabs hast du durchschnittlich offene ich würde sagen 60 oder so und was macht
die craft ql api habt ihr schon irgendwas damit damit gebastelt oder wollt ihr oder
irgendwie beauftragt oder so 100 tabs ja ob 100 tabs geht es erst los ich finde das video
nicht mehr keine ahnung ich hatte einen richtig cool richtig coolen clip wo ich es nicht auf
bekommen habe schief wie könnte das heißen china steckdosen leiste flasche mit custom
firmware ist es wahrscheinlich nicht excellent nein das ist es nicht bastel irgendwas mit
bastel
keine ahnung stream titel alter stream titel flash warum findet er flash nicht ist es bugged
dass die suche ist einfach das nee moment
es muss es muss was sein mit kamera oben
das ist das richtige nein das ist das falsche weil sag mal wie viele flash streams hatten
wir eigentlich schon der bot nicht funktioniert echt nicht angeblich an der bot was gesagt
leute ich habe zu viele zu viele streams gemacht in dieser richtung ich finde es nicht mehr
zumindest ich habe versucht eine einer von diesen steckdosen leisten zu öffnen und ich
habe es ums verrecken nicht hinbekommen und ich habe dran rumgezerrt also die hier meine
ich die hier meine ich und ich habe dran rumgezerrt bis ich am ende geschafft habe mit dem schraubenzieher
das hier hinten aufzubrechen dass ich dass ich an die innereien komme und am ende kam
raus dass es hier vorne
dass es hier vorne unten drunter eine schraube gibt die man einfach aufschrauben kann das
ganze ding geht easy auseinander na gut ok haben wir uns das angeguckt was denn das 3d
brille oder so ich würde sagen wir haben uns jetzt slamper was für ein ding was soll
denn das sein ach ist das für eine lampe da kann man da kann man eine lampe reinstecken
so und dann schalten ok das ist das ist fife hat wenn man unbedingt seine alte lampe weiter
verwenden will na gut 129 flüchtling guten tag aber ich finde es cool dass sie hier vor
geflasht das motordinger haben das finde ich sehr pock finde ich das gut aber kommen
wir mal zur eigentlichen geschichte zurück was ich eigentlich heute machen will also
falls irgendjemand den clip findet zeige ich ihn noch mal aber ich finde es oft die
schneller nicht habe zu viele streams gemacht ach ja frage stimmt ok was habe ich übersehen
ach so was hast du für eine heizung ne das war nicht die frage aber sehe ich hier gerade
ich habe von wiesmann eine und bei wiesmann braucht man vorne so ein opto link kabel von
denen damit man das auslesen kann was hältst du von alti beratern beziehungsweise eine
karriere darin da müssen wir endpunkt fragen also ich halte von alti beratern zumindest
von den meisten die ich so kenne wenig aber ja das heißt nicht dass man nicht karriere
darin machen kann also die meisten consultants bei denen frage ich mich immer wer konsultiert
die eigentlich zu irgendwas gut wir haben es letztens auf youtube gesehen dieses video
von von der beraterin die excel tabellen macht und wenn man für excel tabellen schon berater
braucht dann weiß ich auch nicht das excel grill genau so jetzt muss chat chat weiß
ich nicht gab es beim spiegel letztens was ja da frage ich mich auch teilweise bei den
leuten so ok jetzt ganz kurz mal weil die hälfte nicht da war wo ich gezeigt habe also
ich habe im canon raspberry pi stehen mit diesem board an diesem board am analog digital
converter was angeschlossen und ich muss checken ob es über 20 volt ist was da anliegt
so es gibt eine python library dafür github aber mein programm was ich eigentlich dann
starten möchte beziehungsweise nicht das programm wahrscheinlich mein programm was
was machen soll wenn das über 20 volt ist in dotnet programmiert für dotnet gibt es
nix das einzige was ich gefunden habe ist github uno square heißen die glaube ich die
hatten mal eine raspberry pie dotnet core library das da so und die library kann angeblich
den ads 1 0 1 5 das ist der analog digital converter der hier drauf ist wenn das foto
höher high res wäre könnte ich euch auch zeigen wahrscheinlich nee ich kenne mich
bei elektro trein ich kann die dinger immer nicht auseinander halten wahrscheinlich der
hier oder ich habe keine ahnung vollkommen egal so zumindest der das recht das da oder
was meinste was ist das das da wäre blöd den so weit weg zu machen davon oder das da
das da wahrscheinlich ich habe da aber kein plan vor wie dem auch sei es gibt eine library
für dotnet die diesen sensor oder diesen diesen analog digital converter unterstützt
das problem ist nur ich habe das gestern kurz ausprobiert ich zeige euch das auch gleich
das dauert fünf minuten haben wir was zusammen gewurschtet und auf den raspberry pie kopiert
übrigens 14 euro ist mega günstig gerade also wer das ding gebrauchen kann es gibt
aber eine neue version die hat auch ein display noch drauf zumindest das funktioniert nicht
ich habe gestern was zusammen gewurschtet und damit ausgelesen es kam sonst was raus
ich zeige euch mal wie es richtig aussieht also ssh pie ad ok was für eine ip hat das
ding im keller 1 9 2 1 6 8 1 2 9 ja das ist der richtige 11 hat ist der richtige raspberry
pie ich habe meine raspberry pies natürlich so benannt dass man nicht versteht was es
eigentlich ist ich weiß total hängen geblieben ich kann mir die ip nicht merken und die dinger
haben namen die nichts mit der funktions zu tun haben vielleicht sollte ich die dinger
wenn ich sie schon nach emotes benenne wenigstens irgendwie halbwegs weiß ich funktionsbezogen
benennen aber nein raspberry pies sind fucking teuer geworden ja soll ich dir mal sagen
ich hatte richtig glück ich habe in österreich bei sem sem sem a t sem a v a t habe ich einen
raspberry pie gefunden eine 8 gigabyte variante raspberry pie 4 mit mal gucken ob sie wieder
geht 9 80 euro das ist gar nicht mal so teuer für die 8 g variante ich meine es ist immer
noch irgendwie fragt mich nicht 20 euro über uvp aber das geht und in kombination mit dem
offiziellen netzteil und dem flier case habe ich in anführungen strichen nur 120 euro
bezahlt habe das netzteil und habe das case dabei das ist gar nicht so schlimm das problem
ist aktuell dass du normale raspberry pies schon für 120 euro ausgehen muss wenn du
bei amazon guckst leute ich habe mega hunger vielleicht müssen wir gleich asmr eating
stream machen wenn du bei amazon guckst die preise sind die preise in absolut kein great
alter ich meine dafür kriegst du schon desktop pc jetzt nicht übertrieben dafür kriegst
du wirklich ein desktop pc nicht den geilsten und auch bestimmt nicht den aller neuesten
aber es ist auf jeden fall auf jeden fall viel zu teuer das sind immer irgendwelche
unsinnigen kids also leute ich sage ich sage die kids lohnen sich überhaupt nicht da sind
immer sachen dabei die keiner braucht erstens gucken wir zum beispiel dieses kit an ja dieses
kit ist ein gehäuse dabei das könnte sogar von den farben den farben nach ein offizielles
case sein bin ich mir nicht sicher diese geschichte aus rot und weiß ist meistens das was die
auch gerne als offizielles case verwenden aber zumindest dieses case sieht mir nicht
aus als möchte ich das haben vor allem mit aktiv kühlung alter mit aktiv kühlung hängen
geblieben also das sind case dabei was ich nicht will lüfter geschütte was ich nicht
will ne ssd die ich nicht brauche ne mikro sd nicht ne ssd ne mikro sd die ich nicht
brauche und wahrscheinlich ja ok das netzteil mag mag ok sein keine ahnung braucht man nicht
genauso wie das hier das willst du auch nicht haben vor allem das ganze zeug was hier dabei
ist das ist einfach billiges china chinesen zeug was cent beträge kostet mit dem wir
das aufplänen ja usb ding braucht keiner den adapter und die sd karte braucht keiner
den lüfter braucht keiner was ihr braucht ist meiner meinung nach das beste gehäuse
für den raspberry pi ist das hier clear case das clear case ist passiv gekühlt es ist
komplett komplettes alu gehäuse und das funktioniert folgendermaßen das hat in der mitte so ne
dalle genau das hat in der mitte so ne dalle und das drückt auf der anderen seite auf
die hier sieht man es das drückt auf der anderen das wird ein wärmeleitpad mitgeliefert
das drückt auf die cpu vom raspberry pi und dadurch verteilt sich die abwärmen über
das komplette gehäuse und das reicht reicht und es ist gar nicht mal so teuer deswegen
ich bin der meinung beste kombination ist tatsächlich clear case raspberry pi seiner
äh vierer das ist fürs vierer raspberry pi seiner wahl ich persönlich würde ja sagen
nehmt die 2g variante wenn es um den preis geht aber aktuell ist das scheiß auch mega
teuer ich finde 2g variante ist preisleistungsmäßig noch noch am besten weil viel mehr brauchst
du für die anwendungsgebiete auf raspberry pi eh nicht und nehmt euch ein ordentliches
netzteil dabei weil das offizielle raspberry pi netzteil ist ein 5,1 volt netzteil warum
auch immer 5,1 und nicht 5 5 war gibt es ein paar aber ihr könnt potenziell jedes x beliebige
netzteil nehmen zumal es auch normale usb charger tun mit wenn ihr die schon habt normale
usb charger tun 5 volt 2 ampere das reicht also der raspberry pi meckert im schlimmsten
fall dass dass er das dass er andervoltet ist oder so aber es passiert meistens nichts
ihr werdet halt ein bisschen weniger performance haben wie nicht normale ladegeräte natürlich
das funktioniert mit normalen ladegeräten auch ich meine der raspberry pi 4 ist stromhungriger
wenn ihr maximale performance haben wollt und auf nummer sicher gehen dann nehmt es
offizielle netzteil oder nehmt einen 5 volt 3 ampere netzteil aber wenn ihr nur normalen
usb charger habt mit 5 volt 2 ampere das reicht auch der kackt euch da wegen nicht ab ich
wüsste jetzt nicht warum ich das nicht nehmen sollte das sagt andervoltage error genau
dann tackte er sich wahrscheinlich runter wenn man natürlich auf brutalste stabilität
und also ultra stabilität und 24 sieben voll last und was auch immer setzen will ja dann
schon aber das willst du ja meistens nicht was nicht bei mir ander wollte der nicht
ich hab den im wohnzimmer auch an einem 2 ampere netzteil hängen ja das funktioniert
aber ladegeräte sind für das laden ich mein achso ja ne du hast recht ich mein keine ladegeräte
ich mein diese dinger diese stecker mit 230 volt zu usb die dinger meine ich also diese
teile die du ins die du in die steckdose steckst und 2 usb stecker dran hast so ein teil habe
ich auch im wohnzimmer seit drei jahren oder so die meinet also das hat das ist nicht warum
das nicht nicht tun sollte warum sollte man das nicht nehmen ich meine das ist im prinzip
ja nur ein 230 volt auf 5 also 5 volt dc umwandeln also wüsst jetzt nicht was das nicht für
dauerbetrieb aber gut wenn du es besser weißt mich würde interessieren warum nicht so aber
jetzt kommen wir zu eigentlich sagen radios signale sagt warte sehnsüchtig auf den 0 2
ich habe 302 daheim habe ich mir zur release bestellt und ich weiß nicht was ich damit
machen soll ich habe einfach welche da ich habe einfach welche gekauft ah ok verstehe
also zumindest mein raspberry pi meckert nicht von ander voltage also wenn man raspberry
pi das heißt was du mir sagen möchtest ist wenn man raspberry pi ab und zu abkackt dann
könnte das daran liegen aber der kackt ja nicht ab aber sollte er abkacken dann dann
könnte das daran liegen also wo sind wir stehen geblieben genau das ding auslesen bin ich
eigentlich jetzt alles los geworden ja hier raspberry pi case sonst wie ok also genau
also ihr seht diese library gibt es heute noch ein gewinnspiel für ein raspberry pi
0 jetzt wo du sagst wir machen wir machen kein gewinn wobei nein machen wir nicht weil
es geht du musst mir was zu ausdenken wo habe ich die überhaupt ich habe nämlich extra
mehrere bestellt bei einem shop der mehr als eine bestellung zugelassen hat wo habe ich
die denn überhaupt ich hatte die letztens letztens hatte ich sie noch in der hand ah
ne die habe ich in meine eine controller kiste geschmissen glaube ich egal die brauche ich
jetzt eh nicht ist wurscht die habe ich in meiner kiste wo die ganzen controller dinger
drin sind so also wir basteln jetzt mal schnell was und ich zeige euch dass es nicht funktioniert
normalerweise sollte folgendes passieren guck mal ich habe die ich habe die library hier
schon ausgecheckt automation hat das ist die offizielle python library die wir nicht verwenden
können weil mein programm was ich ausführen will in dotnet ist so examples hat da gibt
es ein analog punkt bei der macht nix anderes wie alle 250 millisekunden also alle viertel
sekunde den analog sensor auszulesen und den output auszugeben also wenn ich das jetzt
ausführe dann kommt sowas raus also das sind das sind die werte die aktuell an dem analog
digital konverter anliegen war schwankte bissl also irgendwas um 17 17 bis 18 volt natürlich
die easy variante wäre jetzt ich mache dotnet programm was mich dann auf dem handy anruft
über sieb und lass das einfach ich könnte ja einfach sagen if value größer 20 und
dann kann ich ist das die richtige ip syntax für python leute bin ich so der krasse python
hacker und dann kann ich hier drinnen das programm aufrufen aber wir wollen das ja
komplett in dotnet machen nicht sieb sieb sieb telefon telefon sieb ich weiß gar nicht
was es heißt protokoll protokoll internet was heißt sieb speech internet protokoll keine
ahnung gucken wir mal session initiation protokoll moment was hat es mit voip zu tun
die sprache ist gar kein sieb das ist einfach nur quasi hand gescheike hand gescheike für
für für dann voip oder wie warum sagt man dann immer sieb das ist doch total bescheuert
eigentlich müsste das dann rtp klein heißen oder ein sieb rtp klein oder so
du kannst die analog werte auch unter sys bus elo die was woher will er wissen das das
was das für einen sensor ist kann ich nicht ich habe nicht mal die weiß ist ordentlich
aber vielleicht möchte es als gut machen sys bus i-square-c die weißes name bcm ne das
ist das ist das ist der controller oder das ist der das ist der rtp die das der chipsets
vom rtp also worte ich habe keine ahnung wie du da drauf kommst oder oder wusstest du
nicht dass ich auf raspberry pi bin hast gedacht ich bin auf dem auf meinem dell kiste
übrigens habt ihr gelesen wenn ihr eine fritz box habt und bei der telekom seid müsst
ihr firmen wir abgehört machen sonst könnt ihr nicht mehr telefonieren hier also vor
ihr lang covid habt erst mal updaten was wurde aus dem unrate steht im serverraum hinter
mir das problem ist ich habe kaum was gemacht die letzten drei wochen weil ich eigentlich
mehr oder weniger ein paar kleine unterbrechungen die kunde wo ist das ich habe kein krank emote
weil er weil er weil ich sich sicker bin quasi seit drei wochen und ich da nicht sondern
ich viel antrieb habe was zu machen aber jetzt es ist ja langsam besser noch kein produktiver
betrieb ne ne ne so also wenn ihr fritz box habt und damit auch weiter telefonieren wollt
und einen telekom anschluss habt dann müsst ihr updaten nämlich auf 729 aus weil weil
die irgendwelche sachen jetzt standardmäßig verschlüsseln oder so ich habe da folgt nur
kurz drüber drüber gelb geskippt so also das ist das ziel das teil hier auszulesen
bcp dann blub cao nein das will ich nicht machen ja also das das ist das ziel das ding
auszulesen und wie gesagt in pyson kein ding aber ich will es in dort net machen deswegen
machen wir uns den kram mal kurz auf auf github auf und gucken was da was da intern so passiert
was worty pock zeigt mal her was ist das ja genau für den suche ich was wenn er per
eiskursierung gibt es dafür ein köln modus jetzt wird es advanced stelz texas instrument
da muss wahrscheinlich einfach das passende moduladen oder hi fat time this driver implement
support for texas instrument oder muss ich das selbst kompilieren oder ist das dabei
von ks und wie benutze ich das linux driver korn von der gunter mann und trunk gmbh der
hat das programmiert das wäre cool wenn das funktioniert ich bin im fachkräftemangel
zum opfer gefallen nee ich bin im hals weh hals weh da ja nicht möglich mangel zum opfer
gefallen moment das ist nicht da da muss das muss ich per c auslesen oder das ist nix
wo es irgendwie ein trock eintrag gibt oder oder doch die die die doko ist mir ein wenig
weiß ich wenig aussage kräftig schweifers ilo na gut da machen wir alles wie war das
ellers mod nee das ist was ich geladen habe wie kann man alle verfügbaren module auflisten
oder ist es doch ellers mod minus e nds nee modprobe minus l war ich so selten list all
modules linux korn jetzt brauchst du das hier linux re recompile shirt ja list all audible
die ernsthaft seriously jetzt da keine schöne raub von ks mod info so kräpp minus e nds
ich kann köln modul dafür laden ok
wait a minute ernsthaft wenn das funktionieren würde wäre easy as fuck da müsste ich ja
überhaupt nichts machen wo steht hier was mit ilo
hier oben im titel ok ok mod asudo modprobe das da ok hat er geladen
wo das hätte ich mal das offizielle netzteil verwendet so als gut ok was was war das süß
heute ich hab's vergessen was schrei was nee
eo ernsthaft das gibt's jetzt die weißes
hat er nicht erkannt wie bring ich das ist eigentlich gar nicht das was ich machen wollte
aber wenn das mit nem korn treiber geht ist ja schon wäre ja schon richtig pock die weißes
treiber da muss man nicht rebooten für das mod jetzt soll das ja eigentlich geladen haben
ja muss man da vielleicht noch parameter mitgeben wenn man die lädt das kann ja sein dass man
parameter braucht für adresse zum beispiel die parameter mit der adresse
alter jetzt wirds aber jetzt wirds aber sehr lilux technisch abgedreht documentation ich
hab keine ahnung was ich hier kocke was aha
da ist aber nix guck mal da ist nix
da ist nix drinne guck geht schon mal nicht weiter
also das hat nicht geklappt mit dem laden
wir können aber mal machen i-square-c-detect-y1 guckt hier da ist er adresse 48 dass das
das ist das sensor was war das mod minus für entfernen
so wie bedient man den krempe also ich bin ich bin deutlich zu pepega dass das zu verstehen
was das mir hier sagen möchte ehrlich gesagt checkt das irgendjemand
required properties channel number ok
i-square-c-address kann man wie gibt man bei modprobe noch mal modprobe parameter wie
geht denn das noch mal fedora erklärst mir
einfach hinten dran einfach parameter ok ok ok ok ok modprobe und dann einfach sowas
thickness mit mit mit contains
Dreck.
Nee.
Alter, gibt's da kein, ah, gibt's da nicht ein gescheites Beispiel für Mann?
Modprobe.
Es wäre mega nice, wenn das mit Colonel Treiber funktionieren würde.
Raspberry Pi, ADS auch, weil der ist auch nicht ADS, NT, oder was?
Alter, hab keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert.
Colonel Modul not working, ja, sehr schön, zeig her.
Oh, man muss nicht einfach nur, man muss ne, ne, äh, das ist irgendwie Raspberry Pi
special shit.
Da muss ich den restarten, ich will den nicht restarten, boah, das ist ja wieder die Wissenschaft
für sich schlechthin.
Leute, Chat, Chat, irgendwelche Ideen, irgendwelche, irgendwelche clawreichen Ideen, Moment,
es gibt noch, es gibt noch ein normales, nee, steht da nicht ein REC Beispiel drunter, ja,
aber den gibt's, es gibt angeblich überhaupt, ja super, das ist, das ist irgendwie, es gibt
das, den Parameter angeblich gar nicht, Data Rate, Data Rate gleich, haben wir irgendwie
keine Ahnung, 5, ob das jetzt funktioniert, nee, TI, minus, nee, nee, nee, das, das,
das TI ist noch drinnen, das andere, unknown Parameter, also Leute, das, das funktioniert
so nicht, Modprobe, man findet dazu auch nix, oder muss ich das mit Overlay machen, aah,
wait a minute, muss man das mit Modprobe, Parameter, wie macht man das denn richtig,
ich schreib das bestimmt falsch, Stack Overflow, Stack Overflow, also Leute, kannst du dir
alle Parameter ausgeben lassen, tja, wenn ich wüsste wie, Options, Monka S man, Modprobe,
Lists, Para, List Module Parameters, wow, nee, nee, alle Parameter, Modinfo, also Modinfo,
TI, Modinfo, aha, obvious, obvious, Moment, da muss man bestimmt Modinfo Parameter, muss
man bestimmt noch irgendwas angeben, Param, P, minus P, gibt keine Parameter, hä, wie,
da gibt es keine Parameter für, da steht in der offiziellen Doku aber was anderes
drin, dass es da Parameter für gibt, Monka S, Anzeige ist raus, was ist das hier, muss
man das doch über dieses komische Aufwand, ich mein ich kann den Raspberry Pi neu starten,
das ist kein Problem, nicht, dass da jetzt irgendwas wahnsinnig wichtiges drauf läuft,
das ist was nicht, ne, nur wenn er nicht hochkommt, wer doof, aha, ihr postet einer, Links, gucken
wir uns gleich an, Properties, ungleich Parameter, das kann natürlich auch sein, das kann natürlich
auch sein, alles komisch, mach es lieber auf deine Art im User Space, ja, das, das, das,
Properties, ich bin da echt zu PP gefühlt, ich weiß nicht, wo ich bin, ok, hier, ok,
config file, das ist das falsche, ok, man muss das irgendwie mit Overlays machen, ich
starte das Ding jetzt, wir probieren das jetzt einmal aus, wir probieren das jetzt einmal
aus, diese Boot Config, ja, die Sache ist nur die, es gibt doch angeblich, warte, wo
hatten wir jetzt, wo hatten wir jetzt das GitHub Issue hier, ah Mist, Overlay, da, da steht
ja nichts, drinnen, was wir nicht schon wissen, da stand irgendein Parameter drin, den es
angeblich nicht gibt, oh, der Browser, der blendet, oh, oh ne, wo stand denn der Scheiß
denn jetzt, was als Overlay, DT oder sowas, nee, Sekunde, ich muss mal kurz Licht einschalten,
und ich hab Hunger, ich muss glaube ich gleich was essen, aber wir können ja, ich kann ja
unpleiben, wir fordern schnell was, ja, Leute, ich verstehe auch gerade nichts, Moment, ich
hatte doch eben ein Beispiel, wie der Kram funktioniert, hier, DT, Overlay, ADS, Address,
so, das Problem ist nur, das ist diese, TI, ja, DT, Param, what, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne,
ne, ich mein mit Modprobe dahinterschreiben geht ja gar nicht, also wenn ich sag Modprobe
da irgendwas dahinter schrei, null, das geht ja nicht, also ich bin ja nicht in der Lage
Out zu figuren
Das geht nicht bei strikes das ist der alte
Das ist der alte das ist das ist nicht der hier guck
Das ist der alte wir haben wir haben ti ads
Andere parameter
Also irgendwie bin ich bin ich zu dumm bin ich zu dumm für dafür das ist ich kapier es nicht was ich da machen soll
2 pp gar nein funktioniert nicht siehst du doch da guck da geht nicht ja funktioniert nicht
Weißt du was bevor ich jetzt da noch ewig ewig rum suche ich mache jetzt erstmal die nette variante
Und irgendwann habe ich dann vielleicht kapiert wie man wie man den kram verwendet
Feind war das feind ades guck mal der hat noch nicht mal für den 115er treiber drin hat nur den
Warum ich meine kram nicht in python schreibe weil was das machen soll ist folgendes
Wollen wir das bild wenn an dem analog digital konverter über 20 volt anliegen soll es mich anrufen auf dem handy und ich habe eine
Ziemlich gute sip library für dotnet das habe ich auch schon alles fertig natürlich ich könnte die easy mode variante machen
Das in python auslesen und dann einfach mein dotnet programm starten aber ich will ja gucken wie es im dotnet geht
Die einfache variante kann jeder
Ok leute ich glaube das muss ich irgendwie anderweitig checken wie das wie das funktioniert
Modprobe ich finde nicht mal ein beispiel für ich finde nicht mal ein beispiel für wie man den kram
überhaupt laden soll das python programm von dotnet aufrufen das würde auch funktionieren ja aber viel schöner ist
Natürlich aus dort net direkt das auszulesen das ist mir way to five hat das zu checken wie das funktionierte
Modprobe module properties
Fällt man gar nichts zu nice nicht modprober modprobe
Da bin sogar ich noch linox noob zu viel zu viel für das zu checken
Ansonsten keine ahnung was der uns damit sagen möchte
Was ist hw mon das dachte ich mir
Lasst halt python laufen und es ist was kann man alles machen ja aber es ist viel nicer das direkt aus dort net auszulesen
Vor allem weil ich nicht weiß wie es funktioniert mich interessiert wie es klappt ok scheiß drauf das gucke ich mir irgendwann anders an keine ahnung wie das funktioniert
Wir gucken uns doch das falsche an oder
Das ist das falsche das ist die falsche doko die wir uns hier angucken wir gucken uns wir gucken uns die ganze zeit die an wir müssen uns die hier angucken
Getting started
ganz bestimmt nicht. Parameter. Ne. REC. Aber REC sollte es geben. Property Read. Ok,
was macht dieses Modul? Wo sollte ich überhaupt was finden danach jetzt? Ich glaube wir gucken
einfach falsch. Nur dass das halt null, doch ich checke es nicht wie es funktioniert. Vielleicht
muss man es einfach nur laden und das dann nachkonfigurieren oder so. Wo sind wir hier
wieder gelandet? In welchen Teilen des Internets, Alter? Ich mein, wir können das einfach nochmal
laden. Mod Probe. Also das Ding hat ja anscheinend keine Parameter. Es hat keinerlei Ausgaben,
was es macht. Nur mit dem Unterschied, dass es jetzt unter Sys-Dings-Devices gibt es auch
nichts. Drivers gibt es auch nichts. Dann check ich es auch nicht. Ne, das reicht mir jetzt.
Da bin ich zu ppega für. Das habe ich da gefunden. Nix. Holy Luck Games, danke für den Sub. Das
von Intel, ja dann wundert mich nichts mehr. Wobei Intel macht tatsächlich ganz gutes
Linux Zeug meistens. Excellent, alles klar. Es sollte sowas geben wie Rec, aber da muss
ich einen Node anlegen. Muss ich da irgendwie einen eigenen Device Node anlegen? Ist mir
komplett ein Rätsel, was die da von mir wollen. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Ach so, nicht den
Plast und Schimmer. Gucken wir nochmal, wir haben noch ein Kernel-Documentation. ADS, BAM.
Ne, ne, nicht 5.3. Dock. Was ist denn aktuell? Latest, ADS. Super, gibs den mal. Ne, Leute,
wirklich keinen Plan. Okay, ne, wir machen jetzt die.NET-Variante. Also hier checke
ich nichts, irgendwie was ich da machen musste. Gut, also, next, raus damit. Also, wie gesagt,
die Python-Variante funktioniert. Automation-Head, examples, analog, mit.NET, den AD-Auslösen
ist doof. Ja, das Problem ist, es gibt keine Library dafür. Oder besser gesagt, es gibt
eine Library. Also das sind die Werte, die eigentlich rauskommen müssen gleich. Es gibt
eine Library, nämlich die hier. Ne, das ist die Python-Library. Die hier, die angeblich
diesen Sensor unterstützt. Ich hab das gestern auch schon ausprobiert. Wir machen jetzt einfach
mal ein neues Projekt. Gestern ausprobiert, die Sache ist die, ich würde mich immer noch
interessieren, was ich auf dem Bing Image of the Day sehe. Sieht für mich immer noch
aus wie Pfadfinder, 1922 oder so. Die Werte stimmen bloß nicht, die da rauskommen. Das
ist total pepega, was das aussieht. Total unsinnig. Also, new solution. Leute, wir brauchen
einen guten Projektnamen. Das ist der ADC-Champ. Mach doch mal einen Screenshot davon, Haus
in die Google-Bildersuche. Von was? Ach, da, von hinten, von dem Hintergrundbild, ja.
ADC-Champ. X der Solution. Bester Projektname. Das find ich gut. Das mach ich irgendwann,
Mathe. Irgendwann nenn ich meine Solution wirklich X der Solution. Das find ich nice.
ADC-Champ. Oder wir könnten es auch ADC-Champ nennen, aber da hört es eher nach Active
Directory an. Was einfach Mast nennen, warum Mast? Telefon Mast. Mast. Masta darf man
auch nicht mehr. Masta ist doch, Masta ist doch outdated, shebaited, overrated. So,
mit 6, console application, create, wunderbar. Zip ADC-Champ. So, jetzt müssen wir mal kurz
gucken, wie wir das cross compilen können für den Raspberry Pi. So, also, was haben
wir hier? Hallo Welt, perfekt, genau das will ich ausführen. Rider, ADC. Leute, habt ihr
was dagegen, wenn wir schnell was futtern? Ich hab übelst Hunger. Warum hast du ein
Projekt namens ShareX? Tja, das ist ein Desktop Screenshot Programm. Leute, ich hol mir
mal kurz was zu futtern, ich hab mega Hunger, das kann ich nicht denken. Bin gleich wieder
da. Eat good. Bin gleich wieder da.
Ich hau mir mal schnell was rein. Wollen wir irgendwie, wir können Barbecue Pit Boys
kochen beim Futtern. Wir machen gleich weiter. Richtig gesund Banane. Das andere. Nintendo
Striked, keine Twitch Streams. So. Was gucken wir denn jetzt? Heroic New Proposal
für Javascript. Ich muss irgendwas gucken, beim Essen, damit ich euch nicht so sehr ins
Ohr schmatze. Naja gut, das ist ja auch nicht schwierig. Ich mein, ich sag dazu nur. Die
müssen da ja gar nicht anstrengen. Guck mal, die haben fast mehr Spieler. Das hätten die
sich im Traum nicht überlegt. Das hätten die nie gedacht. Aber die haben auch irgendeinen
Playtest oder so. Battle Bit Remastered, ja. Das ist dieses Pixel Style Ding. Naja gut,
das hat auch nicht wirklich viel. Aber es ist schon echt hardcore, lächerlich. So,
wir müssen uns jetzt irgendwas angucken, da ich euch nicht so sehr ins Ohr schm... Ah,
das Video hat mir jemand auf Twitter geschrickt, der technisch da nicht so ganz so versiert
hat. Ich mein, was halt ich da heute? Ich fand es nicht schlecht. Können wir uns tatsächlich
angucken? Ich brauch nur irgendwas, was läuft, damit ich euch nicht so sehr ins Ohr schmatze.
Und wo ich bisschen was zu sagen habe. Was haben wir denn sonst noch zur Auswahl? Heroic
New Proposal für Javascript. Okay, was? Woah, fuck. Okay Leute, was wollen wir uns zuerst
angucken? Was haben wir denn noch alles hier? Was haben wir denn hier noch? Most futuristic
advanced automations ever. Und wir gucken uns das Javascript Video zuerst an. Und dann
machen wir Raspberry Pi Zeug gleich weiter. Schon! Schon! Ist das schon so lange am Start,
Javascript, ja? Ich hab Typescript mal als es ganz neu, als ich glaub sogar noch Beta
war, hab ich damit ein bisschen rumgewurstet, dass Javascript erträglich ist. Ähm, danach,
aber damals hatte ich noch weniger Ahnung von Javascript, wie heute. Danach war der Trend
irgendwie oder zeitgleich oder zeitlang, man macht alles in vanilla Javascript, dann hab
ich mir das ein bisschen angeguckt und komm damit jetzt eigentlich ganz gut klar. Ich
bin noch nie so auf diesen Typescript Train aufgesprungen. Leute, was meint ihr? Lohnt
sich das? Ich weiß, dass es viele Projekte hat, haben und die nicht wieder zurückswischen,
aber für so kleinen Scheiß, wie ich mach, sagt ihr das lohnt sich? Typescript? Auf
jeden Fall. By the way, Leute. By the way, wer sich fragt, was ich vorgelegt hab, ist
was ich fordere, Toastbrot mit Hähnchen. Troph. Was für Sensoren ausgelesen werden?
Ein Analog-Digital-Converter auf diesem Board. Das wär geil, oder? Das wär geil. Typescript
ohne Typescript. Das haben sie geskippt. Ja, das haben sie geskippt, ES5.
Leute, wer ist so pfeifend im Chat und weiß, für was ES steht? Das ist das einzige bei
JavaScript, das ich weiß an Abkürzungen, deswegen muss ich das jetzt mal wichtig tun.
Wer weiß? Ah, der Bindstrike, schon wieder. Ja, richtig.
Das macht aber keiner.
Ah, es war grad die Frage, wofür ECMA dann steht. ECMA steht für European Computer Manufacturers
Association. Hab ich bei Wikipedia auf dem zweiten Monitor
nachgeguckt? Also nicht, dass man denkt, ich hätte das jetzt irgendwie gewusst oder so.
Es wäre schon cool. Es wäre schon cool, wenn man Typechecking im Browser hätte. Direkt.
Übrigens, ich müsste mich von irgendeinem Snack-Hersteller sponsoren lassen, dann würden
wir einfach in jedem Stream einfach 10 Minuten was futtern. Wobei das auch wiederum schlecht
ist, weil dann werde ich noch dicker. Was ist passiert?
Ja, juck mich nicht. Hauptsache, im Zweifelsfall, dass man seine
Anwendung komplett neu schreiben muss.
Was? Gamer-Suppe? Es gibt Gamer-Suppe? Ehrsache?
Ok, schauen wir uns das andere an.
2015. Ich glaube, die meisten Leute, die ein bisschen technisch versiert sind, bei denen
hat sich schon rumgesprochen, dass Antivirus zum größten Teil Crap ist.
Da gab es auch noch keinen Windows-Defender, der so gut fragt.
Ein derartiges Ungleichgewicht kommt nicht einfach so zustande. Das ist das Ergebnis
harter Arbeit. Erforschen wir also mal, ob und wenn ja was, Antiviren-Software zu einem
falschen
Leute, was meint ihr? Kann man noch Kaspersky einsetzen? Geht Kaspersky noch? Das sind
ja auch gekommen.
Die Metapher des Schlangenöls zu verstehen ist dabei nicht ganz unwichtig. Mitte des
19. Jahrhunderts nutzen chinesische Bahnarbeiter in den zentralen Bundesstaaten der USA das
Öl von chinesischen Wasserschlangen, um die eigene Arthritis zu behandeln. Das sprach
sich irgendwann rum und sorgte auch ohne wirklichen Wirkungsnachweis dafür, dass fahrende Händler
schnell Imitate herstellten, die kaum bis kein echtes Schlangenöl enthielten, aber
als
man sich das Schlangenöl ausdrückt, war es mir komplett neu, warum habe ich eigentlich
Untertitel an?
Sollte man sich auch nur ausdenken konnte, sollte mit diesem mysteriösen Elixir geheilt
werden.
Im besten Fall.
So, wisst ihr was heute wäre? Heute würdest du das auf Beauty-Channels finden. Da siehst
du dann Dagi Bee oder irgendwer. Ich war heute zufällig im Supermarkt und habe dieses tolle
Schlangenöl gefunden. Es kommt aus der südamerikanischen, super seltenen, ähm, schwarzen Bananenschlange.
Es ist wunderbar für eure Haut. Das kann ich mir richtig gut vorstellen. Die würden
den... mit Klobulis drin... mit Klobulis drin, genau. Die sind in der Schlange, sind die
schon drin, die Klobulis.
Falsch, miss man einfach nur sein Geld zum Fenster raus und realisierte den eigenen Fehler
kurz nachdem der Händler die Stadt wieder verlassen hatte.
Häufig haben als Schlangenöl verkaufte Pampen aber die Gesundheit der eigenen Kundschaft
zusätzlich noch verschlechtert.
Und dieser letzte Punkt ist besonders relevant. Es geht beim Vorwurf, etwas sei ein Schlangenöl,
häufig nur um ein Besserungsversprechen, das nie erfüllt wird, aber hier geht es explizit
auch darum, dass das Besserungsversprechen nicht nur nicht erfüllt wird, sondern manchmal
auch gegenteilige Effekte erwirkt.
Im Fall von Anti-Viren-Programm bedeutet das, dass die Sicherheit nicht nur nicht erhöht,
sondern sogar reduziert wird. Und na klar, in den meisten Fällen sitzt der Grund für
den Befall von Schadsoftware vor dem Bildschirm und legt das Argument nahe, dass der Virenschutz
nicht auf der Festplatte, sondern im eigenen Hirn stecken sollte.
Ist ja auch so. Brain Exe kannst du mit nichts überbieten. Mal ganz davon abgesehen, theoretisch
würde es mich nicht wundern, wenn Leute heute noch mit Windows 98 im Internet sind und sich
noch nie ein Virus eingefangen haben, weil sie nicht auf jeden Scheiß draufklicken.
Gut, Windows 98 gebe ich jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben, aber das ist ja
auch, was ich schon oft in meinen Videos gesagt habe, gegen ein bisschen Nachdenken oder umgedreht
muss ich sagen, ein bisschen Nachdenken kann euch der beste Virenscaler nicht abnehmen.
Das wäre mit Sicherheit auch eine vielversprechende Realität, aber jeder, der mal versucht hat,
der eigenen Oma nachhaltig zu erklären, welcher Downloadknopf auf Softtonic der richtige ist,
wird wissen, wie utopisch diese Vorstellung ist. Das funktioniert wirklich nicht.
Software-seitige Virenprävention hat also eine Dase. Wichtig ist, wichtig ist, nehm
mal den Windows Defender, den würde ich tatsächlich auch eingeschaltet lassen, wobei man sagen
muss, der Windows Defender hatte auch schon die einen oder anderen Sicherheitslücken,
die dann quasi Einfallstore waren. Ich sag nur diesen JavaScript-Interpreter, der mit
Ruthrechten läuft im Windows Defender. Gab's schon ganz abgedrehte Sachen. Aber was wirklich
sehr sehr praktisch ist, wenn man eine Linux-VM hat und mit der auf, sagen wir mal, etwas
zweifelhafte Dinge geht, dann hat man eh schon mal keine Probleme. Was aber auch wichtig
ist, ist entweder NoScript im Firefox oder zumindest sowas wie UBlock Origin oder sowas
zu haben, was schon mal den meisten Müll rausfiltert. Das bringt schon mal richtig
viel und eins muss man auch sagen, Browser sind heute, das müssten eigentlich das Einfallstornummer
eins sein, weil es quasi keine andere Software auf dem Rechner gibt, die permanent Code
ausführt aus fremden Quellen, was es letztendlich ist, wenn du auf irgendeiner Internetseite
gehst. Aber dafür sind Browser mittlerweile wirklich erstaunlich sicher. Du siehst relativ
selten was und mit dieser riesen Angriffsfläche, die Browser aufgrund ihrer Komplexität bieten,
aufgrund ihrer Verbreitung bieten und eben halt auch weil es die erste Verteidigungslinie
ist, wundert man sich wirklich, dass da nicht täglich 20 neue Sicherheitslücken rauskommen.
Vielleicht geht das da. Das habe ich mir schon angeguckt. Das ist das gleiche, was
die in dieser Library eingebaut haben, die ich gefunden habe und es funktioniert nicht.
Da wir nicht alle technisch affin genug sind, um Linux zu nutzen und daraufhin...
Ich benutze übrigens Archlinux, möchte ich an der Stelle nochmal hervorheben.
Alles in unserer Macht stehende zu tun, um das jeden in unserem Umfeld wissen zu lassen.
Das habe ich übrigens auch, wo wir gerade dabei sind, der Welt mitgeteilt unter diesem
Video irgendwann. Das ist nämlich ganz entscheidend wichtig, dass ihr in der Welt mitteilt, wenn
ihr Archlinux verwendet. By the way, warum kann man eigentlich nicht richtig scrollen
unter YouTube-Videos? Warum geht das nicht? Ich benutze Archlinux, by the way. Das ist
ganz wichtig, dass man das der Welt mitteilt. So, Feststell-Taste. Man kann auch Knuh-Hurt,
ich weiß nicht, wie man das ausspricht, verwenden, genau. Übrigens, wo wir gerade dabei sind,
das ist ja auch nicht Linux. Wer hat das passende Emote? Allow me to interject for a moment.
Das ist ja auch nicht Linux, das ist ja GNU-Linux. Sonst kommt hier Richard Stallman um die Ecke
und schaltet den Stream persönlich ab. Genau, so sieht's aus.
Kannst du deine E3-Config teilen? Ja, hab ich schon. Github, Wubblords. Ist nicht top
aktuell, aber aktuell genug. Hier, guck mal. Ja, E3-Status und config E3. Das kenne ich,
die Seite. Das ist tatsächlich save for work, ja, die kenne ich. Und hier ist mein E3-Config,
ist zum größten Teil eigentlich default. Stimmt, Emacs kann aktuelle Seiten nicht laden,
da kann man den Stream gar nicht anschauen. Oder vielleicht schickt ihr mir an den Stream
ein paar E-Mails zu. Ziemlich effektiv. Zwar haben sie den eigenen Amiga ordentlich verlangsamt,
aber Programme und Code, der ihnen unterkam, auch mit einem Katalog an tausenden bekannten
Viren und Trojanern verglichen. Bei einer Übereinstimmung konnte sofort interveniert
werden. Dieses Signature-based getaufte Verfahren existiert bis heute, umfasst aber nicht nur
in der E-Mail. Das Bild ist geil. Das ist gut. So geil. Ich habe mich verschluckt,
ich benutze Arch. Das ist top. Hast du die Archweifel gesehen? Das wundert mich nicht,
was es da so was kippt. Archweifel, okay, ist das... Okay, es ist Unix-Porn, die Seite
ist save for work. Na, das ist eher was für die Weeps unter uns. Aber das Bild ist echt
gut, das muss ich mir merken. Wo sind wir stehen geblieben? Da. Sack, Leute, ich muss
was zu trinken holen, ich habe mich gerade übelst verschluckt.
jetzt gucken wir aber das Video endlich mal, fertig. Einige tausend, sondern
ein paar Mehreinträge. Der Nachteil dieses Verfahrens ist aber ziemlich groß, schließlich
muss Schadsoftware, um dingfest gemacht zu werden, erst mal bekannt sein. Die Jungfernfahrt
eines Virus ist also stets frei von Eisbergen. Doch nicht nur Viren haben sich dem Zeitgeist...
Nicht immer. Mittlerweile versuchen sie sicher schon seit ein paar Jahren an Verhaltenserkennung
bei Anti-Viren-Software. Das klappt so, naja, also... Da wird auch öfters mal Sachen erkannt,
die nicht gefährlich sind. Geist angepasst, sondern ihrer vermeintlichen Nemesis genauso.
Heutzutage ist es üblich, dass Virenschutz nicht mehr nur nach bereits bekannten Übeltätern
sucht, sondern von ihnen verlangt wird, wie ein Keil in die Berechtigungsbarrieren eindringen
zu dürfen, um alles sehen zu können, was im Inneren so abgeht. Wer das nicht zulässt,
weil das zugegebenermaßen ein gehöriges Maß an vorausgehendem Vertrauen benötigt, der
wird mindestens bei jedem Systemstaat freundlich darauf hingewiesen, dass man gerade blutend
im Haifischbecken schwimmt. Neben diesem enormen Vertrauensvorschuss, der bei eigentlich kaum
einer handelsüblichen Virenschutzsoftware gerechtfertigt ist, weil es offenbar zum
guten Ton gehört, möglichst detailliert... By the way, Avira und Norton haben jetzt auch
Kryptominer in ihrer Anti-Viren-Software. Richtig Five Head Move. Und von den gemeinten Bitcoins
oder nee, was ist das? Ich weiß nicht, was die meinen. Dann bekommen die sogar noch einen
Share ab. Also, das ist ja schon wirklich fast Mailware-Praktik. Auch wenn sie sagen,
das ist standardmäßig nicht an, aber allein schon, dass das eingebaut ist, ist doch...
Das will man eigentlich nicht haben, ja. Ich weiß nicht, ähm... SOS, genau.
Detaillierte Nutzerprofile zum Ad-Targeting, weiter zu verkaufen.
Erinnert sich noch jemand daran, an die Zeiten, wo man irgendwie 90 Euro oder so im Jahr bezahlen
sollte für Norton Internet Security, für die Norton Internet Security Suite und die dich
dann unten in der Taskleiste alle 15 Sekunden darüber informiert hat, dass ein Hacker-Angriff
abgewehrt wurde. Das war auch so ein absoluter Scam, das ganze Ding.
TuneUp Utility On nennt... Nicht dieses Wort. Mein Vater hat sich das immer gekauft, TuneUp.
Er hat gemeint, sein PC ist unbenutzbar ohne TuneUp. Vielleicht ist das Problem gar nicht
so sehr, dass der PC lahm war, sondern TuneUp war das Problem. Das wäre ja auch möglich.
Gibt es noch ein viel größeres Problem? Der Keil, der jetzt in der Schutzschicht unseres
Systems setzt, kann mit nur einem erfolgreichen Trick zu einem 1A-Tor ins Heiligtum werden.
Kurz ist der Virenschutz mit Admin-Zugriff überlistet, steht der Weg ins System.
Ja, da hat er recht. Das kam schon öfters vor, als man denkt. Auch im Windows Defender.
Im Moment der Virenschutzfirmen ist dabei häufig immer das Gleiche. Ja, das mag ja
alles sein, aber viele Leute, gerade technisch eher ungebildete, haben keine Lust oder keine
Zeit sich ein vorsichtigeres Verhalten am PC anzugewöhnen.
Tja, manchmal, die haben ja damit nicht unrecht, aber dann können sie einfach den Defender
weiterverwenden. Und ganz ehrlich, du kannst nur immer sehr schwierig Leute vor sich selbst
beschützen. Wenn du jemanden hast, der unbedingt gegen die Wand fahren will, weil das geil
findet, gegen die Wand zu fahren, kannst du nur sehr beschränkt was gegen machen.
Mindestens genauso wichtigen Bereich, die Folgen suggerierter Sicherheit. Klassische
Virenschutzprogramme von Drittanbietern haben ein hohes Mitteilungsbedürfnis. Sie müssen
sich ständig legitimieren. Ständig ein Vergleich.
Da hat er recht. Das ist das, was ich eben auch gerade gesagt habe mit diesem, wir haben
wieder einen Hacker abgewehrt. Die wollen permanent zeigen, guck mal hier, alles ist
gut, weil du uns gekauft hast. Und vielleicht macht man dann auch Mist, den man nicht gemacht
hätte ohne Anti-Viren-Software.
... zwischen ihrer vermeintlich effektiven Anwesenheit und den dramatischen Folgen ihrer
alternativen Abwesenheit kommunizieren. Jeder Tag ist ein Ring um eine mögliche Deinstallation,
weil viel effektiverer Virenschutz mit modernen Betriebssystemen gleich mitgeliefert wird.
Jeder Tag ist eine Werbemaßnahme auch auf dem nächsten Computer genutzt zu werden und
nicht zuletzt auch ein Anraten, die noch effektivere, kostenpflichtige Version des Programms zu
nutzen.
Und diese jahrelange penetrante Überzeugungsarbeit trägt ihre Früchte in Form dieses Ungleichgewichts.
Das ist nicht nur ein tolles Beispiel für den Mirror-Exposure-Effekt, nachdem...
Moment, wo sind die anderen 50%?
... positiver Einstellungsänderung daherkommt, dass man einfach immer und immer wieder gesagt
bekommt, wie toll etwas doch sei, sondern auch ein weiteres, inhärentes Sicherheitsrisiko.
Denn die Einstellungen, Anti-Viren-Programme würden halten, was sie versprechen und ihre
Anwesenheit wenigstens etwas mehr Sicherheit ins System bringen als ihre Abwesenheit, sorgt
dafür, dass man sich unter Umständen selbst weniger kritische Gedanken um das eigene
Verhalten macht.
Da ist was dran, ja.
Leicht sinniger wird, weil man ja Vorkehrungsmaßnahmen getroffen hat.
Doch der Höhepunkt falscher Versprechen befindet sich in den App-Stores der Gegenwart.
Mobile Virenschutzsoftware ist kompletter Wahnsinn.
Eine übergängige Wege installierte App hat gar keinen Zugriff auf die inneren Vorgänge
des Systems.
Da bin ich mir bei Android nicht so sicher, keine Ahnung, ob man dort nicht irgendwie
zumindest weitergehende Rechte anfragen kann oder wie auch immer.
Unter iOS auf jeden Fall nicht.
Unter iOS hast du gelitten.
Das stimmt.
... abseits ihres limitierten Zugriffsbereichs gar nicht gucken oder agieren, sodass ihr
Einfluss extrem eingeschränkt ist.
Eine Untersuchung der 10 bekanntesten Anti-Viren-Apps hat zudem ergeben, dass nur eine einzige
keine erhobenen Daten an Drittanbieter weitergibt.
Im Zentrum dieser Debatte steht die Frage, ob die teils massiven Sicherheitslücken von
Anti-Viren-Programmen die generelle Gefahr, die durch den aktuellen Nutzer des Systems
ausgeht, verringern oder erhöhen.
Und die Variable in dieser Gleichung ist nicht der vermeintliche Virenschutz, sondern der
Nutzer.
Das Betriebssystem integrierten Virenschutzmaßnahmen von Windows und gerade von Mac funktionieren
hingegen deutlich besser.
Macs Gatekeeper dreht den Spieß beispielsweise um und versucht nicht alles zu blockieren,
was bösartig ist, sondern stattdessen nur das gewähren zu lassen, das gesichert.
Das probieren die ja unter Windows auch mit ihrem Smartscreen oder wie das heißt.
Nur, dass die Leute da mittlerweile schon so sehr drauf trainiert sind, drauf zu sagen,
ja, run anyway, juckt mich nicht, run anyway.
Du hast sogar schon offizielle Herstellerseiten, wo drin steht, sollte so ein Popup kommen,
einfach run anyway drücken.
Aktuell gilt aber Virenschutz, gerade der von Drittanbietern, ist in den meisten Fällen
wahrscheinlich schlimmer, als die Viren, die man sich ohne oder durch ihn eingefangen
hätte.
Und das ist furchtbar schade.
Ja, da hat er recht.
Ja.
Also ich glaube, das war wirklich auch für technisch nicht so versierte Leute, hat er
wirklich sehr anschaulich und gut gemacht das Video.
Cookie-Meldung, ja gut Cookie-Meldung, das ist ja nochmal was ganz anderes.
Die Cookie-Meldung musst du ja heute machen, dass hier nicht irgendwelche Abmahn-Typen
aufs Dach steigen.
Ach, das war 42% der Lion-Versus-Experten, achso, nee, da brauchst du wirklich keine
anderen 5%.
By the way, ich bin fertig essen, wir können weitermachen.
Defender, fertig, mehr brauchst du nicht.
Wie gesagt, wenn du noch einen Browser hast und dann sowas wie NoScript oder Uplog Origin
oder so verwenden, das ist nochmal deutlich besser.
Und alternativ, wenn du auf irgendwelche, ja, shady Seiten gehst, mach das über den
Deluxe-VM.
Dann kann dir nichts passieren, genau, es gibt ja bestimmt schon Addons, die das automatisieren.
Ja, ich würde auch das Windows-Interne verwenden, umgute es.
So, also, machen wir mal weiter, wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben?
Also, wir waren nicht in der Lage, den Crempel zu laden mit dem Modul, okay, achja, okay,
also, für alle, die in der Zwischenzeit dazugekommen sind, weil wir haben gerade was gefuttert,
das eigentliche Ziel ist, ich hab im Keller einen Raspberry Pi stehen mit diesem Board,
dieses Board hat einen Analog-zu-Digital-Converter und ich will den auslesen, nicht offiziell
mit dem offiziellen Pi-Sending-Library von denen, sondern aus.NET raus, weil ich ein
Programm hab, was mich über SIP anruft, was getriggert werden soll, wenn das hier über
20 Volt geht.
Das war eben, ich bin gerade mal am gucken, wie man das über.NET macht.
Wie hast du Ryder eigentlich aktiviert, Lizenz oder so, Lizenz, ich hab ne offizielle Lizenz,
guck.
Ich hab das All-Desktop-Paket, äh, verbaut, ja, Lizenz 2 Max-K, das stimmt schon, wirklich
viel gemacht, aber nicht, ja, so ungefähr, also ich gucke, das ruft permanent die Spannung
ab und wenn es über 20 ist, ruft es mich auf dem Handy an, so, also jetzt, wir bleiben
aber bei diesem Hallo-Welt, weil ich will mal kurz gucken, wie ich das Cross-Compile
zum Raspberry Pi, also ADC-Champ, ADC-Champ, ähm, boah,.NET-Geschiss aus dem Kopf, Sekunde,
äh, warte mal, es ist auf jeden Fall.NET-Publish, ich hab kein Autocomplete,.NET-Publish,
.NET-C-Release, das ist, glaube ich, denn, äh, R für, für Linux ARM, was bedeuten
die 20 Volt, die 20 Volt bedeutet, jemand hat draußen an meiner Klingel geklingelt,
das ist so ein ganz, ganz merkwürdiges Encoding, also, 18 Volt ist Ruhe, Ruhe-Spannung, 24,
25 Volt ist es klingelt, 15 Volt ist die Tür-Gegensprechanlage wurde abgenommen und wenn sie wieder aufgelegt
wird, dann geht es zurück auf 18 Volt, ähm, minus Output in einen Bildordner, jetzt will
ich haben, oh, wie war das mit Self-Contained, minus, minus Self-Contained-Bild, ach guck
mal, da haben wir es doch hier schon, lull, na geil, ah, nee, Moment, Linux ARM, so, dann
bilde das mal, so, wenn ich das jetzt richtig gemacht habe, sollte da ein Executable rausfallen,
was auf dem Raspberry Pi einfach auszuführen ist, so, R-Sync, Bild, nach Pi-Ed 192.168.1.129,
ok, ach Moment, äh, minus, minus A, was, minus A, das ist AV, ja, ok, Bild, muss ich
den Kram erstmal rüber kopieren und gucken, ob ich es dann ausführen kann, aber durch
R-Sync geht es jetzt beim nächsten kompilierten Vorgang deutlich schneller, so, slash, adc-champ,
hello world, ok, also so können wir die Sachen auf dem Raspberry Pi ausführen, wir machen
da ein Kommando draus, wir bilden das, wir machen das anders, wir bilden das, dann schieben
wir es per R-Sync rüber und dann machen wir einen SSH und führen es gleich da drüber
aus, weil dann ist es zum testen einfach schneller, cd-build.slash-adc-champ, schauen wir mal, ob
das jetzt funzt, ja, funzt, ok, kann ich dem Amazon Liefermann 20 Volt auf die Klingel
setzen, wenn er nur die Klingel wieder abhaut, ja, äh, könntest du wahrscheinlich mit dem
passenden Schalter, aber 20 Volt wird dir nicht großartig jucken, ist ja nicht so, als
würde man das, als würde man das groß merken,
also das funktioniert, gut, dann schnappen wir uns mal diese komische Library, die wir
hier auf GitHub entdeckt haben und fügen die mal hinzu, also ich zeige euch das, was
ich gestern mal ausprobiert habe schon, Offstream, Uno, Uno, Where, Raspberry Pi IO, Peripherals,
genau, das braucht man nur, ich zeige euch jetzt mal, dass es nicht funktioniert, so,
dann war ich nämlich sogar noch bei denen in GitHub und habe nach ads hier in dem Ticket
geguckt nach einem Beispiel, wie es funktioniert und da ist mir folgendes aufgefallen, noch
nicht mal das Beispiel aus dem Ticket ist lauffähig, oh, was muss ich sonst noch, was
muss ich sonst noch, ich muss sonst noch was hinzufügen, Uno, Square, Wiring Pi, so, und
jetzt werdet ihr gleich sehen, ads gained, so, allein schon das Beispiel funktioniert
nicht, weil ich brauche hier kein I-Square-C-Device, sondern muss direkt hier die Adresse angeben,
also es scheint mir, als hätte ich sogar noch irgendeine uralt Version, also keine Ahnung,
die Packages sind echt nicht das Gelbe vom Ei, Start-Lese-Zyklen-Analog-Werte, deutsches
Ticket, können wir halt wegmachen, so, und jetzt kopiere ich das mal rüber und gucke,
was passiert, wenn ich das ausführe und ihr werdet sehen, es funktioniert nicht, da kommen
Schwachsinnswerte raus, guck, 2, 2, 3, 2, das heißt, ich muss jetzt erst mal gucken,
was die Python-Library macht, vielleicht machen die ja noch irgendeinen Magic-Krams dabei,
zumindest mit, damit komme ich jetzt nicht wirklich, ach so, ich glaube, ich habe sogar
das falsche, ich muss Channel, by the way, ich muss Channel 0-Readen, war schon mal verkehrt,
nein, ich habe 17, 17, 17 Volt habe ich, ok, das mag schon sein, jetzt ist nur die Frage,
wie mappe ich das auf 17 Volt und ich habe gestern auch schon ein bisschen geguckt, und
zwar in die Library von, also das ist quasi der Hersteller von diesem Board, wo der Analog-Digital-Converter
drauf ist und ich habe was gefunden, also ich weiß, ich weiß ungefähr, was ich machen
muss, also, hier, Analog-Input, machen wir gerade mal auf, Analog-Input, klasse, das
ist easy as fuck, wie viel Bit hat der, 12 Bit, Referenzspannung, keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich
3,3 Volt, wie beim Raspberry Pi alles, mein Chat was, ach so, ich dachte, ach so, ne, ne,
ah, 5-Hat, alles klar, jetzt ist nur die Frage, wie ich das da raus bekomme, ne, USB-C, das
geht rauf auf glaube ich 20 Volt für Quick-Charge und Gedöns und Konsorten, das bleibt nicht
auf 5, du musst die Referenzspannung durch 2 hoch 12 mal das, was du raus, Moment, Moment,
das machen die hier auch, guck mal, ich erinnere mich, also, wir gucken uns jetzt mal zusammen,
wir gucken uns jetzt mal zusammen den Code an, den diese Python-Library macht, weil genau
das machen die hier auch, guck mal, das habe ich nämlich gestern schon gesehen, die sagen
Get Voltage durch 3,3, so und Max Voltage ist 25, zumindest übergeben die das hier,
ok, also wir rechnen das erst mal, das habe ich gestern aber schon ausprobiert, da kam
Müll raus, so, also, wir programmieren das jetzt erst mal ordentlich, Await, Task, Delay,
keine Ahnung, 250 Millisekunden, Value gleich, so, dann teilen wir das, dann sagen wir jetzt
hier, keine Ahnung, wir geben es einfach aus, Value durch 3,3, dann sollte ein Double rauskommen
und das geben wir jetzt mal aus, mal gucken, was dann rauskommt, schick mal den Link zu
dem Teil, dann schicke ich dir die Formel, das ist ein ADS1015 oder was für ein Link
zu der Library oder, so, R-Sync, rüber kopieren, mal gucken, was jetzt rauskommt, zum Herd,
da kommt jetzt 340 raus, der hat noch einen Spannungsteiler, aha, aha, ok, das ist der
hier, guck mal, genau, genau der, also da kommt jetzt, also ich habe keine Ahnung, wie
ich da jetzt auf 17 komme, deswegen habe ich gedacht, wir gucken einfach mal, was diese
Python Library macht und die machen, das habe ich hier nämlich schon gerade auch gesehen,
die machen durch 3,3, das mache ich auch, aber die machen noch, mal Max Voltage und
Max Voltage ist 25 in dem Fall, nur wenn ich das mache, guck hier, 25,8,5, wenn ich das
mache, kommt absoluter, kompletter Schwachsinn raus, ich habe keine Ahnung, ob ich den Kram
nennen soll, wenn ich das hier jetzt nehme und sage mal 25,8 oder was es war, da kommt
kompletter Schwachsinn raus, nichts, was irgendwie, das ist, was ich haben will, was soll das
sein, das ist nicht 17, das heißt, du teilst 24, also wahrscheinlich teile ich nicht 24,
sondern 25,8,5 denke ich mal, printe mal die Rohdaten, das sind die Rohdaten, was anderes
kann diese Library nicht auslesen, 100, 1100 ungefähr sind die Rohdaten, was anderes haben
die nicht, das ist ja das Dove da dran, da steht 24, die offizielle Library macht aber
25,8,5, okay also, ich meine, wir haben ja nicht umsonst ein 5-Hat Embedded Poggers Engineer
hier, das sagt mir jetzt, wie das Ganze funktioniert, also was mache ich jetzt, 24, also 24, weil
das Ding 24 Volt maximal, 12 hoch, ah ne, das geht ja nicht, Maß, ne, Exp, okay, meine
12 hoch 2 kann ich aber eigentlich auch als Zahl eingeben oder, das muss ich hier nicht
rechnen, einfach 1000, achso 0, 4096, da hätte ich auch selbst drauf kommen können, 0, ist
das das gleiche?
Ach ne, das ruft man auf auf schon eine andere Zahl, okay, was 24 durch, ne, das kann ich
doch auch ausrechnen, das muss ich doch da eigentlich gar nicht reinschreiben, okay doch,
das schreiben wir da rein, also was meinst du, das muss ich machen, 24 durch das, mal
mein Wert, mal den da, den Wert, den ich schon durch 3,3 geteilt habe oder den Reach Channel,
wahrscheinlich den da, ne, mal, jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt, war es D, ist es kleinen
D oder Groß D für Double, D, B ist jetzt was, Double, was war Groß D, Decima, ne auch
Double, okay und da kommt jetzt das raus, was ich brauche, Raw Value, also das da, da
bin ich jetzt mal gespannt, ob das Funstern, Kegweight, ne, ne der Gain stimmt, der Gain
ist, oh ne der Gain stimmt nicht, Gain ist, Moment, das habe ich hier in der Library drinnen,
Gain ist glaube ich 4096 oder so, schauen wir mal hier rein in die Lipp, ich habe so
keinen Plan was ich gerade mache, hier guck, Gain 4096, das heißt wir brauchen Gain, sag
mal her, ja ich stimme allem zu, na geil 4096 gibt es nicht, geile Library, oder wir gucken
mal in das Datasheet von dem Ding, PDF, was die bei Gain schreiben, Gain und KS, Moment
da stand doch gerade was, 1, aha guck mal da, was, da, 6, 4, the fuck, oh fuck, oh fuck,
da stand doch gerade was von 2, 2 thirds oder sowas und das habe ich auch, das habe ich
auch in dem Enum gefunden, datenblätter, hier, Gain, 1, 2, 3, 4, 8, 16, wenn ich da
drauf gehe auf Seite 9 ist nichts da, sehr gut, poggers Verlinkung, nice, Gain, Alter,
keine Güte, du willst Gain 4, das ist die Frage, Gain, oder was das zu finden, Gain,
690, incorrect, da steht was, Gain, ah hier steht das, ne ich will 1, guck mal ich will
1, 1 entspricht, ja das ist die Frage, was muss ich sagen, ja, will ich jetzt 1536, also
quasi vor was 1024 sind oder will ich 1 was 4096 sind, I don't know, so mal gucken was
raus kommt, wenn ich das so ausführe, 11, nein das funst nicht, kommt immer die gleiche
Zahl raus, dann will ich doch 1, mit 1 funst, 1 funst, so und jetzt ist halt die Sache,
Patrick ich glaube schon das das stimmt was du sagst, aber ich glaube diese Library ist
halt einfach crap, wir können mal reingucken was der macht, ok der liest irgendwelche Magic
Register aus, ich hab keine Ahnung, der shiftet irgendwelche Bits aus irgendwelchen Gründen
oder das dann mit 32768, was ist das, 2 hoch 15, oder 2 hoch 15, ja, keine Ahnung obvius
oder chat, komplett obvius was hier passiert, also wer es nicht versteht, cringe, hast du
irgendwie ne Möglichkeit da 5 Volt anzuhängen, nee das Ding steht im Keller, nee hab ich
nicht, soll ich mal das da nehmen, mal gucken was dann rauskommt, bisschen try and error,
nee das stimmt auch nicht, ich hab ne andere Idee, ich hab ne andere Idee was wir jetzt
machen und zwar die Library Version, die ich habe hier ist offensichtlich ziemlich, ziemlich
old, deswegen geh ich jetzt einfach mal bei denen ins Github und kopier mir die neueste
Version davon, von ihrem, was da, nee, wo ist es denn hier, ADC, ah hier, ADC, zeig
mal die Zahlen wie sie aus der Library kommt, direkt ins Terminal ohne Quickmuffs, eh, irgendwas
um 1100 kommt da immer raus in dem Dreh, so und wir müssen jetzt von 1100 auf ungefähr
17 kommen, vor 3 Jahren ja, aber die Version die ich hier runtergeladen habe, über NuGet
ist noch älter, weil die noch bytes als Input für die Adresse haben will und die Version,
was hab ich gestern gedrückt, die Version im Repo möchte tatsächlich schon das Device
haben, deswegen werd ich jetzt folgendes machen, ich copy paste nehm ich den Scheiß, was auch
immer unter welcher Lizenz das steht, who cares, 1x1.5sc, kopieren das da rein, exellent,
jawoll, import, Moment ich hab zu viel, ich hab zu viel kopiert, oh was hab ich, hab ich
jetzt zu wenig kopiert, nee das ist ok, auf der Seite steht es ist beim 25 Volt Eingang
0,015 Volt pro LSB, also müsste man Raw Value mal 0,015 rechnen oder so, ja die Sache ist
halt die, ich weiß gar nicht, ob der Raw Value an sich stimmt, den die hier auslesen, aber
probieren wir mal aus, also Raw Value mal 0,015, schauen wir mal was da jetzt rauskommt, das
ist gar nicht mal schlecht, das ist gar nicht mal schlecht, Patrick ich weiß nicht was du
ausgerechnet hast, kannst du das mit 25 Volt mal mit 25,8 rechnen, also die Python Library
die macht, hast du, ok, also die Python Library, die offizielle von denen ist der Meinung,
dass es Examples hätte, also die Python Library meint es ist 17,7, also wir sind ungefähr
1 Volt off, aber es ist mir ehrlich gesagt nah genug dran, das reicht mir, also vielleicht
ist unseres ja auch genauer als das von denen, nice, ja das wärs doch eigentlich schon,
jetzt müsste ich nur einen haben, der vor das Haus geht und mal klingelt und mal gucken
ob er 20 rauskommt, ich geh jetzt nicht runter und klingel Leute, das könnt ihr vergessen,
hast du nicht vorhin 18 Volt idle gesagt, ja hab ich, ja um die 18, guck hier siehst
sie ja da auch, 17 bis 18, also wenn das im Ruhe Zustand ist die Klingel, das ist interessant
ok, ich hab immer noch keine Ahnung wie du das ausgerechnet hast, aber Five Hair Time,
ist nicht noch der Unterschied, dass die ersten Werte runden, ja aber selbst wenn du das rundest
kommst du nicht auf 17,7, die runden den Raw Wert, nee die runden nicht den Raw Wert oder,
guck mal, die machen, die machen Get Input durch 3,3, Round Value, Value ist das hier
und dann auf die dritte Stelle, nee nee am runden kann das nicht liegen, das find ich
Spock, das finde ich nice, ja dann können wir uns nämlich das sparen was ich hier vor
hatte, mit den Sachen kopieren, wobei ich kopiere das jetzt trotzdem mal, wo sind wir
stehen geblieben, es ist mir zu viel Zeug hier, ich glaube das habe ich gerade geschlossen
oder, ja kopieren wir das hier trotzdem mal runter, Raw Class HDS 1.0.1.5, ja ja Namespace
geh weg, so jetzt ist das ein bisschen neuer und was ich auch schon gesehen hab, die haben
ein bisschen was, die haben ein bisschen was geändert an der Library, man kann jetzt nämlich
sagen Read Channel Raw und nur noch Read Channel, vielleicht funzt das, funzt das ja dann besser,
was machen die da eigentlich für Dinger, Read Channel Raw und dann, Patrick warum teilen
die das durch das, ist das irgendeine Implementierungssache von dem Sensor oder wie oder, oder muss man
irgendwelche Bits wegschiften oder was ist das, wir testen jetzt mal, wir testen jetzt
mal das mit der neuen Version davon, uninstall, so was hab ich denn Kram nicht installiert,
macht auf den ersten Blick gar keinen Sinn, gut zu wissen, Game One, Adress, nee Adress
macht man jetzt nicht, man macht jetzt so, weil das neuer Version ist, so und jetzt führen
wir das mal aus und gucken ob da jetzt was besseres, nee jetzt müssen wir nicht Read,
Read Raw müssen wir machen, oder, Read Raw oder Read Channel, ja was machen wir jetzt,
was ein Schimmer, guck mal ob da jetzt was anderes rauskommt, was machst du gerade genau,
ich, ok wir haben wieder das gleiche, ich hab ein Board auf dem Raspberry Pi im Keller
mit einem Analog Digital Konverter und ich versuch das aus.NET auszulesen und ich kriege
es nicht so wirklich gebacken, also zumindest nicht ohne den Chat, der Chat hat, wir sind
jetzt ja quasi schon mehr oder weniger fast da wo wir hinwollen, also warum es auch immer
ein Wollunterschied ist oder vielleicht skalieren die hier in der Python Library falsch, der
Patrick ist bestimmt 5-headiger als die Library Programmierer, wahrscheinlich ist unser Wert
jetzt sogar richtiger als der, der die offizielle Library ausliest, läuft das.NET als Docker
auf dem Raspberry Pi, nee das ist da direkt drauf installiert, ist Read Channel nicht
eventuell der umgerechnete Wert, deswegen Read Channel wir auch Raw Read Channel, magst
deine Vorgehensweise, er hat kein System und kommt nicht mehr mit, ja als würde ich da
mitkommen, he doesn't know he lacks critical information, warum möchtest du die Spannung
auslesen, aha weil, wenn, oh Moment, komm mal an, weil das an meiner Türklingel angeschlossen
ist und die Türklingel hat so ein bisschen merkwürdiges System, in Ruhe ist es 17-18
Volt, wenn es klingelt ist es 24 Volt, wenn jemand die Tür Gegensprecher Anlage abnimmt
ist es 15 Volt und danach, wenn wieder aufgehängt wird geht es zurück auf 17-18 und deswegen
will ich das auslesen, dass wenn das über 20 geht, dann bedeutet das, es hat jemand
geklingelt und wenn jemand geklingelt hat, dann rufe ich mich an auf meinem Handy per
SIP und schicke mir über SIP das Bild von meiner Torkamera als Videocall, diesen Teil
haben wir schon mal im Stream gemacht und das funktioniert prinzipiell, sogar mit Nutt,
sogar über Nutt, muss hydratet stay in here,
ja Leute, so sieht es aus, ich brauche einen Bonbon, Sack, ich gebe keine 4000 Euro aus
mit einer neuen Klingel.
Re, der Bonbon, welchen SIP Anbieter benutzt du dafür, wo habe ich denn den Account registriert,
ich glaube bei Linfone, aber ich verwende nicht Linfone als Client, das Sackt, ich verwende
auf dem iPhone groundwire als Client, weil das eine der wenigen Apps sind, die Push Notifications
für eingehende Anrufe haben, die meisten SIP Clients die man findet für IOS sind
immer im Hintergrund aktiv und das Sackt einfach, man braucht eine Unnutzbatterie, der hier
kriegt eine Push Notification wenn es klingelt und dann klingelt es, das stimmt, ich frage
mich nur was die anders machen in ihre Library als wir, hehehe, White Strikes wieder in
seinem Element, ich sehe es schon, krasser IT Stonks Business Berater, wo hast du den
angeschlossen, das ist alles in einem, das ist quasi das gleiche, was denn, also Patrick
wenn ich drauf tippen müsste, würde ich folgendes vermuten, du hast komplett richtig gerechnet
und diese 3 Jahre alte Library hat einen Fehler, aber da gehe ich jetzt mal von aus, schauen
wir doch mal was die hier machen, also die machen hier irgendwelche Dinger, Read Raw
Channel, dann teilen sie durch das 32.000, but why, keine Ahnung, weil, so und wir gucken
uns jetzt einfach mal an, was macht denn die Python Library um das auszulesen, die sagen
Get Voltage von ads 115, wo kommt das her, das ist bestimmt eine extra Library die sie
importieren, ads 1015, ja das importieren die wahrscheinlich, müssen wir mal gucken
wo die herkommen, ob die das bei sich haben, ads, ah wahrscheinlich das hier, Get Voltage
macht nur durch 3,3, wobei ne, das stimmt, Get Voltage ist hier in der Library drin,
durch 3,3 machen die in ihrem Update, so da gibt es jetzt ein Get, Get Voltage, da ist
es doch, also was machen die hier, bla bla bla, keine Ahnung, Gain, okay die rechnen
den Gain, gut das ist etwas wo ich keinen Einfluss drauf habe, weil das intern passiert,
Gain mal 1000, Moment, Moment, das kommt mir aber sehr bekannt vor, das ist falsch, das
ist falsch, 32000 sinds für den ads 115 und ich hab nen ads 1015, das müsste nicht 32000
sein, das müsste ein 2048 sein, ob das was bringt, mal gucken, mal gucken wahrscheinlich
eher nicht, aber das ist schonmal falsch was die hier machen drin, das ist schonmal crap,
funktioniert schonmal nicht, so, also, replacen wir das mal und gucken was jetzt rauskommt,
pass auf jetzt stimmts einfach, jetzt stimmts einfach, kommt genau das gleiche raus, Moment,
wir müssen read channel verwenden, nicht raw, wobei das können wir doch selbst ausrechnen,
die machen read channel und den raw value teilen sie nochmal, also, machen wir value,
den raw geteilt durch 2048f, for respects, so, und dann machen wir so, mal gucken was
jetzt rauskommt, 16,8 ist doch gut, ja aber 16,1 kann 17,68, Moment, dann darf ich, dann
darf ich, nee, wait a minute, warte mal, ich mach mal kurz, ich mach mal kurz das was die
da auch machen, du meinst das mal 25,8 und dann soll was sinnvolles bei rauskommen, nee,
da kommt nichts sinnvolles bei raus, also was die machen ist, die nehmen diesen Wert, teilen
ihn durch 3,3, das hab ich gesehen und dann rechnen sie diesen Wert mal 25,8, 25,85 sogar,
please, so, kommt sonst was rausbei, passt auf, fuck, nope, ahhh, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ich hab keine Ahnung, warte mal, hier machen die noch was, guck mal, da muss man mit dem
Gain noch irgendwas machen jetzt, ja, schickt mir mal auf Discord, wisst ihr was wir machen,
ich pass das jetzt hier einfach an und dann verwenden wir, pass mal auf, f, haben respects
gepaid, wir passen das jetzt hier einfach an, dann verwenden wir einfach rechannel,
passen das hier weg und jetzt, und jetzt, ist es ziemlich exakt das, was die, was die
pisenvariante macht, easy, ich hab doch keine Ahnung warum das jetzt funktioniert, guck
mal, easy, genau das, ich weiß nicht was es macht, ich weiß nicht warum es geht, aber
es funktioniert, das sind die richtigen Werte, aber so muss das sein, keine Ahnung warum
es geht, aber es geht, Patrick, falls du es verstanden hast, gut, ich nicht, ich hab das
einfach nur abgeschrieben von dem was die gemacht haben, das hat gerade einmal 32 Volt,
was echt, wo, eh wirklich, wo, von KS, nee oder, immer 17 vorne, oh, äh ich glaube ich
weiß woran das lag, das lag daran, dass es wahrscheinlich durcheinander gekommen ist,
weil ich gleichzeitig mit dem pisenprogramm drauf zugegriffen hab, wahrscheinlich kann
es nicht ab, wenn mehrere Sachen gleichzeitig laufen und versuchen den sensor auszulesen,
das, jaja, guck mal, guck mal, das liegt da dran, das spackt rum, wenn beide Programme
zeitgleich versuchen auf den sensor zuzugreifen, so jetzt muss nur noch jemand klingeln, das
ist wohl wahr, und wisst ihr, wisst ihr was das blöde ist, ich hab keine Möglichkeit
irgendeinen interrupt auszulesen, auszulösen, wenn das da drüber ist, ich muss den kram
pollen, alle 10 Sekunden, oder alle 10 Millisekunden, brrrr, wieviel cpu-last braucht das eigentlich,
oh, schon bisschen viel cpu, oder, einfach nur den sensor abzufragen, sag mal, Moment
Leute, da sind wir, ist das wenn man zu schnell ausliest, also manchmal, manchmal kommt Müll
zurück, bestimmt könnte der elektrotechnische, das ist bestimmt easy, ja, aber da müsste
ich in den Keller, was passiert denn, wenn ich das Delay komplett rausnehme, ja, das
mag er nicht, guck mal, da kommt immer 32 zwischendurch mal, und Null, ich glaub das
passiert wenn man es zu schnell ausliest, was, wieviel cpu-last braucht der denn, wenn
ich's volle pulle reinhau, stimmt, oh ja, das stimmt, terminal printen ist wirklich
langsam, Def Null, naja, naja, geht doch, warum, warum ist das Programm so oft gestartet,
Moment, oh Leute, wir haben 5000 adc-champs im Hintergrund laufen, das beendet sich nicht
richtig, woops, but why, kill, kill all adc-champ, adc-champ, ok, nochmal, ja, 5,5, warum beendet
sich das nicht, wenn ich ctrl c drücke, äh, warum, warum, warum keep das running, was
soll das, soll ich nicht runnnen, keepen, soll gefälligt ausgehen, nach der ssh-verbindung,
was denn für ein Müll, mal gucken nicht, dass meine, von gestern noch läuft, das ding
hieß console-app 13 von gestern, ne, das scheint immer zu laufen, warum keep das running,
ah, ihr kennt mich doch, deng-denglisch immer am start, ich hab schon in meinen Videos
sinnloses Englisch mit sinnloses Deutsch mit Englischfetzen geredet, da war das noch
überhaupt nicht im Trend, da gab es noch nicht mal das Wort Influencer, da waren die
noch so rückständig, dass die auf Emails von YouTube-Channels nicht geantwortet haben,
Humor-Stories wieder, ne, so, ähm, aber das finde ich schon mal extrem nice, dass das
jetzt funktioniert, aber warum das weiter läuft, verstehe ich nicht so genau, wir können
ja mal gucken, was passiert, wenn das, ob das, ob das weiter läuft, wenn wir das in
irgendeinem Task starten und hier nicht in der Main-Loop, gucken wir mal, Task-Run, ah,
sonst hört das ja gar nicht auf, der ist AUXCREP-IADC, ADC-Camp, da ist er, so, abbrechen,
jetzt, guck mal, jetzt, jetzt keep das nicht running, ok, das funktioniert, das muss ich
jetzt insgesamt sagen, ging jetzt tatsächlich einfacher, als ich mir das vorgestellt habe,
weil ich hatte die doofe Vermutung, wir müssen uns angucken, wie man einen ADC über I2C
ausliest und da hätte ich wirklich keinen Bock drauf gehabt, es stoppt running, könnte
man sagen, ja das ist richtig, es keep nicht, nicht running, ja nice, das blöde ist, also
was mir überhaupt nicht gefällt, blöde was mir überhaupt nicht gefällt, ist halt, dass
ich das pollen muss, ich muss alle 10 Millisekunden gucken, ob der Krempel über 20 Volt ist,
was anderes geht nicht, guck mal, jetzt bleibt es auch konstant auf 17, wenn da nicht noch
mehrere Programme versuchen, darauf zuzugreifen, das zu pollen gefällt mir nicht, aber mir
gefällt nichts anderes ein, weil dieser ADS1015, der hat zwar einen Alert Pin, den man setzen
kann, also guck mal, der hat hier so einen Pin, da kannst du Interrupts mit triggern,
wenn der über einem gewissen Wert ist, das Problem ist nur, dass auf dem Board dieser
Pin, nicht geprägt out ist, geprägt outed ist, ob ich mal zu übertreiben, also easy
hier dranlöten, guck hier kann ich den Pin dranlöten, der ist es, guck mal, ich löte
jetzt einfach, Leute ich löte jetzt einfach da, guck mal hier, easy mini, ich löte jetzt
einfach da an den Alert Pin was dran, easy, dann kann ich Interrupts machen, ne, das will
ich aber nicht dranlöten an dem Teil, also ich muss im Hintergrund pollen, wie der Wert
ist, was anderes fällt mir nicht ein, das ist echt kacke, aber gut, was will man machen,
was ist mit dem Relay, das ist ein Relay, was damit ist, das verstehe ich jetzt nicht,
das ist da, das beat vor sich hin quasi, das ist halt da, da ist grad nichts dran, das
for future use wie man so schön sagt, also vielleicht brauche ich das ja noch mal für
irgendwas, ich könnte damit zum Beispiel, keine Ahnung, irgendwas im Keller ein ausschalten
oder so, weiß nicht, wäre es nicht easy einen 20 Volt Relay an die Klingel zu hängen,
wahrscheinlich würde es auch gehen, keine Ahnung, so, jaja ich polle in einem eigenen
Thread, was machen wir hier, ich meine wir können uns jetzt noch irgendeine eigene Klasse
für basteln, dass es ein bisschen schöner ist, keine Ahnung, ADC, so, da encapsulaten
wir das jetzt mal alles, ich habs heut mit denglisch setzen, so, schau mal Distro und
habt ihr eine Erklärung geschickt, was die machen, nice, les ich mal nachher durch, es
tut jetzt ja erstmal, ja, dass ich es verstehe ist optional, aber ich lese mir das nachher
durch, warum ich das nicht machen kann ist ganz einfach, weil ich dann selbst irgendwas
zusammenlöten muss und im Keller anschließen muss und hoffen, dass es funktioniert, hier
habe ich ein fertiges Ding, von dem ich weiß, dass es das richtige auslöst, ne, ihr habt
kein bock, das zu tippen, das kann ich auch verstehen, wenn es länger ist, so, wir machen
mal schnell irgendwie eine eigene Klasse draus, was können wir da machen, ah wir benutzen
meine Lieblingslibrary, reactiv, reactiv extensions, beste, so, dann brauchen wir irgendwie public,
machen das einfach hier rein, den task, so, property, values kriegen wir, values, so und
schon haben wir einen ADC, der Zeug zurück gibt, ordentlich, ohne dass ich mich mit den
drunter liegenden Sachen beschäftigen muss, so und anstatt das, anstatt das, also runden
müssen wir es noch, runden müssen wir es noch, values, next, so, zack, delay 10 ist okay
und dann sagen wir noch, wenn das Ding disposed wird, dann values completed, achso und das
muss ich stoppen, Mist, sonst läuft es ja unendlich lang, so, nur solange es nicht
gecancelt ist, sagen wir hier cancel, so, das müsste eigentlich jetzt noch funktionieren
und jetzt kann ich sagen, wenn das, wenn das Funtzwasch gemacht haben, using ADC, new ADC,
ADC values, subscribe, value, value, so und das ist jetzt viel schicker schonmal, da muss
ich mich um diesen ganzen Müll nicht mehr kümmern, das einzige was ich zum auslesen
machen muss, ist das hier, schauen wir mal ob das funzt, ja nice, na das ist doch mal
was, paste bin, wow, das lese ich mir nachher durch, ja das haben wir doch jetzt schön
encapsulated und jetzt muss ich mich um die ganzen Details nicht mehr kümmern, das kann
ich einfach sagen, hier, ließ mal Werte aus und gib die, gib die aus, so und hier drin
könnte ich jetzt, wir könnten noch mehr mal, guck mal, wir könnten noch mehr, wir könnten
jetzt nämlich die ganzen reactive extensions verwenden, wir können jetzt sagen values,
where, value, größer, ich mach jetzt mal größer, größer das hier, weil sonst kriegen
wir nix raus, größer dem hier und nur dann will ich das ausgeben, ups, hallo, console
sprite line, guck mal das ist doch viel nicer, ich glaube das kann man sogar abkürzen, ja,
guck mal und jetzt filter ich und ich krieg nur noch Werte die größer 17.6.8.7 sind,
was in dem Fall hier der Fall ist, ja, das finde ich cool, jetzt können wir nämlich
den ganzen Kram ordentlich verwenden dadurch, dass wir das in eine eigene Klasse gepackt
haben, so und ich könnte sogar noch, ich könnte, hallo was mit meiner Maus, hallo, das ist
der falsche Maus Zeiger, das, hey, was ist der falsche Maus Zeiger für hier, was ist
das denn, debated, hey, ah ok, jetzt ist wieder richtig, ich kann so nicht arbeiten mit dem
falschen Maus Zeiger, das funktioniert nicht, select, math, round, rounded, auf drei Stellen,
guck mal wie schön elegant wir das jetzt machen können, jetzt haben wir es auf drei Stellen
gerundet, pock, pock, pock, in esp32 grillst du mit 20 Volt, was du machen könntest ist
natürlich den gleichen hier nehmen, den, auch einen ads1015, könntest du so ein Ding
kaufen bei Amazon und den an den esp32 anschließen oder an esp82, das wird auch funktionieren,
wenn der überhaupt, der kann nämlich selbst gar keine 24 Volt, der kann selbst nur 5 Volt,
ok da brauchen wir jetzt FyFat Elektrotechnik Kram, dass man aus 24 Volt das aufteilt mit
dem adc zusammen in der Mitte, dass es Maximum 5 sind oder zwei Widerstände nehmen, das würde
auch funktionieren, man kann sich das irgendwie ausreden, man muss auf die linken Seiten Widerstand
machen, man muss den adc in der Mitte rein hängen auf der rechten Seite, aber da bin
ich zu Elektrotechnik nubig für, also ich bin begeistert, ich hätte nicht gedacht,
ganz ehrlich, ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass wir es hinkriegen, weil ich vermutet habe,
die Library ist einfach broken und kaputt und wir müssen jetzt selbst irgendwie gucken,
wie man in.NET das Ding ausgelesen bekommt und dann hätten wir sowas hier machen müssen,
dann hätten wir sowas hier machen müssen und da wäre ich zu pepega für gewesen, das
zu checken, guckt euch das mal an, das ist ja absolute Zumutung, können wir das mal
ordentlich auf zwei Spaces machen, ich will zwei Spaces, zwei Spaces ist viel nicer,
ich will reformat machen, jawoll, ah jetzt, viel viel besser zwei Spaces, Leute was meint
ihr, zwei Spaces oder ein Space, ich find scheiß Lama, zwei Spaces oder vier Spaces,
ich persönlich mag zwei, ja Tabs, Tabs sind ja mal eher, sind ja quasi vier Spaces, weil,
gibt's nicht, doch es gibt ein Umfragefeature, ich glaub wir haben sogar schon mal die Umfrage
Feature gemacht und ich glaube die meisten haben vier Spaces verwendet, fünf, na fünf
ist sehr merkwürdig, aber was mich immer triggert ist, wie krass weit im Wim standardmäßig,
wenn du auf ne Kiste gehst, guck mal den hier zum Beispiel, Wim, wenn ich da nen Tab mache,
guck mal hier, alter, die Standard Tabweite ist mega, sind acht Spaces oder so, wollen
wir ne Umfrage machen, ich mach mal ne Umfrage, slash poll, vier Spaces versus two Spaces
Tabs, vier Spaces, two Spaces, guck mal mal, dauert eine Minute, schauen wir mal, ich bin
im zwei Spaces Lager, aber ich bilde mir ein, die meisten haben hier vier Spaces bevorzugt,
Tabs sind für die Spülmaschine, heute ist aber wieder massive huge jokes angesagt hier,
okay, ich seh schon mal, dass ich auf jeden Fall in der Minderheit bin mit zwei Spaces,
ich wollte es nicht sagen, ja ist so, die meisten fügen hier kein Tab mehr ein, ganz
davon abgesehen, ich formatier eh so gut wie gar nicht mehr selbst, äh ja selbst, sondern
ich lass immer automatisch formatieren, Tab gewinnt, aber auch Spaces sind vier Spaces
auf jeden Fall beliebter als two Spaces, warum wollt ihr, jetzt mal ne Frage an die Leute,
die vier Spaces verwenden, warum vier, ich mein, das macht das nesting eigentlich viel
unübersichtlicher, also guck mal, wenn ich jetzt noch mehr hätte, dann hätt ich quasi
alles das, quasi doppelt so tief eingerückt, und dann hätt ich quasi schon bei der nächsten
Stufe, würde ich dann hier irgendwo hängen, ja und ich weiß, es gibt die Leute, haha,
einfach nicht so tief nesten, naja, manchmal kommste halt nicht drum herum, ich mein sowas
will man sowas wirklich alles nochmal in ne eigene Methode machen, wozu, du hast einfach
mehr Platz, dadurch kannst du bei längerem Code den Code noch schön erkennen, ok, ja
aber du musst wahrscheinlich auch öfters mal rechts scrollen, oder, sagt pep8 nicht
vier Spaces, pep8 ist dieses Python Ding, ja, keine Ahnung, was sie sagen, aber nachdem
ich kein Python programmieren muss, bin ich auch nicht an den Python Style Guide halten,
vier Tabs und ein Ultra-Wide-Monitor, das ist mal wirklich Pifat, eigentlich vier Spaces,
ok, vier Tabs, das wär noch was, guck mal, da wäre die erste Eindrückungsstufe, wär
quasi auf, da, das ist schon, das wär mir dann doch ein bisschen, das wär mir dann
doch ein bisschen krass, ja, das ist vielleicht bisschen viel, bisschen viel ist gut, da
kennst du gar nicht mehr, wozu was gehört, was kommt als nächstes für den Style Guide,
69 Spaces, 420 Spaces, 69 Spaces, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14,
15, 16, 17, 18, 19, 20, 21, 22, 23, 24, 25, 26, 27, 28, 29, 30, 31, 32, 33, 34,
34, 35, 36, 37, 38, 39, 40, 41, 42, 43, 44, 45, 46, 46, 47, 48, 49, 50, 50, 51 Spaces,
da musst du immer nach rechts scrollen, dass das funktioniert, so, nur so, Clean Coders,
Leute, Clean Coders lieben diesen Trick, es ist einfach nichts mehr übrig, guck mal,
Also im Prinzip ist das eigentlich die sauberste Variante
Schaut mal da, wie krass wir Refactored haben
Vorher hatten wir noch 33 Zeilen und jetzt brauchen wir nur noch 5
easy
Warum hast du keinen Formatter an?
Ich habe in Visual Studio Code immer den Autoformatter an, in Rider aus irgendwelchen Gründen
nicht
Aber ich mache ganz gerne hier trotzdem Reformat Code
Warum ich den nicht an habe ist eine gute Frage
Es könnte sein, weil es in der unter Rider früher gar nicht so einfach war Format und uns safe zu machen
Nun ja Leute, danke schon mal Patrick, du hast mir viel geholfen, sonst wäre ich gar nicht auf die Idee gekommen mir das anzuschauen
Es funktioniert, dann steht ja meinem
Zip anruf, wenn die Tür klingelt und dass ich auf meinem Handy die Kamera vom Tor sehe, nichts mehr im Wege
Einrücken mit Semikolons, kann man das aufmachen oder das?
Wie wird eigentlich eingerückt in Sprachen die rechts nach links schreiben
Rücken die dann umgedreht ein? Reverse indent oder so?
Also quasi Reverse indentation
VSCode, gibt es da für was? Arabische Programmiersprachen, ja warum nicht?
Boah das sieht ja mal richtig angeblieben aus, boah das ist ja grausam, das kannst du ja überhaupt nicht lesen
Hier, so stelle ich mir das vor, Leute die von rechts nach links schreiben die rücken auch so ein
Die Australier programmieren von unten nach oben, ja klar, sind ja auf der anderen Seite
Bunnerscript, ai ai ai, Bengali Charscript, Chinese Basic
Moment, Moment
So lange war, versuche, oh meine Güte
Aha das ist für Peter aus dem Microsoft Call Center, Hindavi Programming System
Irish, wie sieht es denn mit Russisch aus? Russisch gibt es auch, ahja, 76 auf jeden Fall schonmal
Die Russen haben hier wieder ihre eigene Programmiersprache, ernsthaft, na gut in
Kyrillisch, was sonst? Programmiersprache in Kyrillisch, ja da hört es jetzt aber echt auf
Meine Güte, Italienisch, die müssen irgendwas mit Spaghetti heißen, das wäre sonst zu, zu, zu
Okay ne, ich hätte echt gedacht, das muss was mit Spaghetti heißen, weil es gibt ja diese
Sachen mit Spaghetti Code und ich glaube das haben die im englischen Sprachraum, kann man sich auch
was herunter vorstellen, also das nicht Spaghetti zu nennen ist schon eine vettale Chance, guck mal
hier, hier können wir uns Italienisch
Stuzika Statements, alles klar
Why not? Okay Leute, wir sehen uns, ich gehe jetzt auf, bis dann, machts gut, see you